messieurs les ministres la commission
des lois vous auditionne à la suite de
l'attentât terroriste survenu à la
préfecture de police jeudi dernier
mardi nous étions nombreux dans la cour
d'honneur de la préfecture de police
pour rendre hommage aux victimes et nous
avons bien sûr ce matin à l'esprit le
visage des familles des victimes
les conjoints les enfants et les parents
la gravité aussi qui se lisait sur le
visage des collègues de travail pendant
cet hommage solennel qui a été
l'occasion d'exprimer la reconnaissance
de la nation
l'attention personnelle du président de
la république du premier ministre les
membres du gouvernement vous même êtes
aussi dans nos mémoires et ses images
que nous avons à l'esprit nous oblige
nous devons à la mémoire des victimes de
travailler ensemble dans le sens de
l'intérêt national avec pour seule
exigence d'assurer de notre mieux pour
notre action par nos propositions par
notre détermination aussi la sécurité de
nos concitoyens et c'est votre
responsabilité au premier chef
face au terrorisme islamiste
cette audition a été décidé samedi
dernier elle nous a semblé indispensable
ainsi la représentation nationale
les français eux mêmes seront mieux
éclairer je l'espère sur les
circonstances dans lesquelles cette
attaque
est intervenu sur les éventuels
dysfonctionnements que vous avez pu
constater qu'ils ont rendu possibles
ainsi que sur les leçons qui en ont déjà
été tirés ou doivent l'être afin
d'éviter qu'un tel drame puisse se
reproduire dans le réexamen
l'approfondissement ou même la remise en
cause des structures et des dispositifs
et par le renforcement des moyens en
matière de lutte contre le terrorisme
le pire serait certainement de
s'enfermer dans des schémas de pensée et
d organisation immuable sans cesse nous
devons nous adapter à une menaces
multiformes et à des formes d'actions
qui ne cesse d'évoluer de changer de
cible et de save lives et de
s'individualiser avec le risque qu'elles
deviennent de plus en plus insaisissable
vous avez monsieur le ministre
identifier des failles c'est le terme
que vous avez utilisé dans la sécurité
interne à la préfecture de police
vous avez souligné qu'en dépit de ce
qu'on a pris l'habitude de qualifier de
signaux faibles la hiérarchie et les
collègues de travail de michael harpon
n'ont pas jugé nécessaire de formaliser
un signalement qui aurait peut-être pu
provoquer une enquête et aurait permis
peut-être de mettre en oeuvre des
mesures préventives
on ne saura jamais il en résulte une
interrogation fondamentale
un dispositif de sécurité qui
dépendraient principalement ou en partie
du déclenchement des enquêtes par le
supérieur hiérarchique immédiat ou par
des agents membres de la collectivité de
la collectivité de travail d'un
fonctionnaire qui se révèle
rétrospectivement avoir été radicalisé
ne serait-il pas d'une grande
vulnérabilité
lité la tragédie de la préfecture de
police doit nous inciter à des remises
en cause ce ne sont pas les personnes
qui sont visés ce serait hors de propos
ce sont nos modes d'organisation et
peut-être même nos structures
nous ne recherchons pas ici des
responsabilités personnelles mais poser
toutes les questions c'est notre
responsabilité et je dirais même notre
obligation notre devoir
je voudrais rappeler à titre liminaire
mes chers collègues l'objet de notre
audition ce qu'elle est et ce qu'elle
n'est pas nous souhaiterons monsieur le
ministre monsieur le secrétaire d'état
dans le temps qui nous est imparti
jusqu'à 10h30 maximum compte tenu de la
séance publique que vous puissiez
présenter votre analyse sur la nature
des failles que vous avez identifié
exposer les conséquences concrètes que
vous en tirez en nous indiquant les
orientations que vous avez d'ores et
déjà retenus pour modifier nos
dispositifs nous souhaitons aussi
connaître les dispositions prises par le
gouvernement à la lumière des travaux de
contrôle parlementaire déjà réalisé
relatifs à la détection des agents
radicaliser dans les administrations et
aux mesures de protection des services
publics contre le risque que
représentent ces agents je pense
notamment aux derniers travaux de nos
collègues les députés diar et poulies 1
mais également des travaux antérieurs du
sénat comme la commission d' enquête sur
la menace terroriste en 2018 tout cela
dans le respect bien évidemment de
l'enquète judiciaire en cours et avec
les limites liées au secret de la
défense nationale
à cet égard
je rappelle que la délégation
parlementaire au renseignement est
également saisie elle exerce son
contrôle sur les services de
renseignement en étant assujetti au
respect du secret sans lequel la
sécurité de nos agents et l'efficacité
des méthodes d'investigation de nos
services spéciaux pourrait être
compromise du fait de la divulgation
d'informations sensibles
ce qui ne peut se dire ici doit par
conséquent l'être devant la délégation
pour que la mission du contrôle de
contrôle du parlement soient
intégralement en plis au nom des
français et couvrent tout le champ de la
sécurité intérieure la délégation
parlementaire au renseignement a déjà
entendu les ministres à huis clos ce
mardi
il lui appartiendra de mener tous les
travaux complémentaires qui lui
apparaîtront utiles afin le cas échéant
d'adresser des recommandations au
président de la république
ces éléments précisés je vous laisse la
parole messieurs les ministres pour un
propos liminaire de quelques minutes à
la suite duquel mes collègues
souhaiteront vous poser quelques
questions c'est bon merci monsieur le
président à la fois 2
de vos mots d'empathie et je sais que
c'est la pensée de tous les sénateurs
ici présents et de tous les sénateurs en
général de la représentation nationale
des français
merci de vos propos liminaires sur
l'encadrement de nos réflexions et je
dirais même merci de votre démarche vous
avez nous avons échangé dès ce week-end
sur la nécessité qu'il y ait cette
audition pour que nous puissions
présenter ce que nous pourrons présenter
à la représentation nationale nous
l'avons fait dans le cas de la mission
parlementaire du renseignement vous
étiez présent monsieur le président et
le président cambon était là évidemment
la mardi matin ne l'ont fait devant la
commission des lois de l'assemblée nous
faisons aujourd'hui devant vous c'est à
la fois notre responsabilité mais je
crois que c'est aussi dans notre échange
notre rôle que de veiller à cette
transparence totale pour ce dont on peut
connaître et de ce dont on peut parler
parce que jeudi dernier cet homme
informaticien affecté à la direction du
renseignement la préfecture de police a
assassiné quatre de ses collègues nous
cinquième personne dont les jours ne
sont plus en danger
heureusement a été blessé gravement et
donc évidemment c'est à eux que nous
pensons et je dirais c'est à eux que
nous devons cet exercice à la fois de
vérité mais qui relève de la justice
mais à la fois d'obligations dans les
réformes permanentes que nous devons
construire sur ce sujet de la lutte
contre le terrorisme et vous l'avais dit
dès vos propos liminaire il n'y a pas de
dispositif efficace en 2013 qui pourrait
ne pas être revu en 2015 ne pas être
revu en 2017 ne pas être vus en 2019
j'insiste tout de suite sur ce point la
vérité de ce que nous allons analyser
sur des failles ou des
dysfonctionnements qui aurait pu se
connaître en 2011 en 2013 et 2015 je ne
parle pas spécialement de ce dossier
n'est pas la vérité d'aujourd'hui et ça
nous appelle aussi à la modestie dans
l'évaluation de cela tout simplement
parce que la vérité de ce moment là le
risque de ce moment là n'était pas celui
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui et de
façon générale il est toujours plus
facile d'évaluer des faits quand on en
connaît l'aboutissement qu'au moment de
la gestion de ces faits je dis cela
parce que comme vous l'avez indiqué
monsieur le président il s'agit pas d'
chercher des responsables encore moins
des coupables
seule la justice est dans cette
responsabilité là cette attaque est en
soi une défaillance grave et nous devons
l'examiner du coup avec le plus grand
sérieux comprendre ce qui s'est passé
comprendre comment un homme a pu se
radicaliser au sein même des services du
renseignement sans que les bonnes
décisions les bonnes actions soient
prises il ya eu des signes
avant-coureurs sioui ont-ils été
signalés à quel niveau
l'anti l'été de façon adaptée idoine
enfin que faisons-nous maintenant est
comment empêcher que cela se reproduise
en gros c'est la synthèse des questions
monsieur le président que vous avez posé
nous aurons à coeur avec landaise de
répondre à ces questions dans la mesure
où nous le pouvons
modestement aussi à notre place et par
rapport à ce que nous savons nous devons
évidemment à la commission des lois au
sénat nous le devons évidemment aussi
aux familles des fonctionnaires qui ont
été emportées nous le devons à la
préfecture de police elle même à notre
service de renseignement nous le devons
aux français qui aujourd'hui
s'interrogent sur la sécurité qui doit
être irréprochable e m'en assurer
je voudrais vous dire que dès la
première minute du monde à la lutte
contre le terrorisme a été au coeur de
nos priorités
il ya eu la loi sylt sur lequel vous
avez tous travaillent et qui a porté un
dépassement politique des gens soit on
ce sujet est un sujet d'impérieuse
nécessité
il ya eu la décision du présent de la
pub de confier à la dg a si le chef de
file à dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme pour qu' il y ait non pas une
main unique mais un pilote unique et
qu'il n'y a aucun trou dans la raquette
des différents services qui peuvent
travailler il ya eu la création du
service national des enquêtes
administratives et de sécurité je pense
que nous aurons l'occasion d'en parler
mais il ya surtout aussi ce travail
acharné de nos services de renseignement
et et je veux à travers ces auditions
les propos du président de la république
les votre monsieur le président que nous
puissions leur redire que cette
défaillance que cet événement dramatique
n'ébranle en rien la confiance que nous
leur devons pour leur travail permanent
ils oeuvrent dans l'ombre il oeuvre face
à des enjeux majeurs dans lequel seuls
les défaites sont visibles mais la
réalité c'est que depuis 2000 13 59
attentats ont été déjoués
mais nous ne pouvons pas ignorer ce
drame on se dise on le travail a été
fait non il y a eu effectivement des
failles qui nous ont conduit à constater
ce qui s'est passé jeudi
mais je voudrais vraiment insister si
vous permettez encore une seconde sur ce
sujet sur le fait que dans nos positions
laurent de neste et moi je crois qu'il
n'y a pas un jour nous n'aurons pas une
information destinée au ministre sur une
intervention de nos services de sécurité
dans la prévention du risque terroriste
pour que des signalements à risques
deviennent pas des risques justement et
je vous le dis mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs tous les genres tous les jours
qu'il y a dans notre pays où le niveau
terroriste reste un risque un niveau de
risque élevé
il ya tous les jours des interventions
mardi devant la commission la délégation
pour le renseignement nous aurons pu
évoquer l'ensemble des dossiers à notre
connaissance y compris ceux qui étaient
classifiées répondre extensivement aux
questions des parlementaires habilité et
vous en étiez monsieur le président et
donc je vous l'avez dit vous-même
nous sommes aujourd'hui dans un contexte
un peu dit différentes tenues par le
nécessaire respect du secret de la
défense nationale auxquels s'ajoutent
les investigations en cours il nous soit
donc impossible d'évoquer un certain
nombre de sujets donc nous vous le
dirons
le plus librement possible et si des
informations que nous ne voulions pas
peuvent quand même relevé de l'échangé
avec la commission on vous fera une
communication écrite sur ces sujets pour
qu'il y ait pas de difficultés
là dessus il ne s'agit pas de s'opposer
des interdictions
mais il s'agit d'éviter de divulguer des
informations dont la divulgation
relèverait du pénal voilà avant de re
laisser la parole à l'euro ne s et de
conclure je voudrais vraiment vous dire
que nous avons à coeur de vous donner le
plus d'éléments possibles afin de
pouvoir faire la lumière sur les faits
et encore plus sur la manière dont ils
ont pu survenir
est ce que nous devrons faire ensuite
même si au mont joux parle tout
l'analyse n'est pas aboutie pour décider
d'un certaines choses mais aussi sur
mesures qui ont été prises immédiatement
au sein de la préfecture de police par
exemple comme plus globalement en
matière de signalement du risque non
merci monsieur mini intérieur monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs jugent juste quelques mots
d'abord permettez-moi d'exprimer à mon
tour est bien évidemment toute ma
solidarité et ma peine après le drame
qui vient de se produire comme vous le
savez monsieur le président j'ai moi
même servi à la préfecture de police de
paris où j'ai été numéro 2 pendant deux
ans et demi entre 2012 4 octobre 2012 et
mars 2015
et donc c'est vous dire si ce drame nous
touche touche ils font pré - à titre
personnel comme ils touchent d'ailleurs
l'ensemble de la représentation
nationale l'ensemble de nos forces de
l'ordre l'ensemble des services de
renseignement et bien sûr l'ensemble la
nation française juste ces derniers mois
il faut bien avoir à l'esprit qu'une
minorité bruyante a mis en cause parfois
systématiquement parfois gratuitement
d'ailleurs les forces de l'ordre leur
travail en matière de lutte contre la
délinquance en matière de protection de
nos concitoyens en matière de gestion de
l'ordre public républicain et que nous
avons donc été tout particulièrement
touché des nombreux témoignages
d'émotion et de compassion reçu depuis
une semaine je veux dire d'ailleurs
aussi pour bien les connaître
comme l'a fait le ministre de
l'intérieur il pour avoir été d'ailleurs
le chef de file de la lutte
antiterroriste en tant que chef de la
dgsi que nos services de renseignement
sont entièrement mobilisés pour traquer
celles et ceux qui veulent nous attaquer
des jouets nous sommes mobilisés pour
déjouer leurs plans et que cet événement
dramatique n'entache vraiment rien la
confiance que nous portons à ses
services de renseignement et de lutte
antiterroriste d'une manière générale je
vais revenir si vous le permettez
monsieur le président très rapidement
sur les faits qui sont maintenant très
clairement connu mais très rapidement
lire venir pour l'ensemble des membres
de la commission
jeudi 3 octobre donc un adjoint
administratif de la préfecture de police
qui est affecté depuis
2003 au service informatique de la
direction du renseignement de la
préfecture de police de paris a quitté
la préfecture donc pour se rendre dans
un dans une boutique dans un magasin où
il a acheté donc deux couteaux un
couteau long et un couteau à huître cet
individu était né le 18 septembre 1974
il souffrait d'un handicap à une été
atteints de surdité depuis son enfance
cet individu après avoir acheté ces
couteaux donc à pénétrer à nouveau dans
les locaux de la préfecture de police de
paris à 12h36 jeudi 3 octobre puis à
12h53 est passé à l'acte dans son bureau
en tuant deux de ses collègues qui
étaient présents au moment de la la
pause déjeuner donc l' enquête ne nous
permet pas encore de décrire précisément
le déroulement des faits mais nous
savons d'ores et déjà de par la
communication qui a été faite par le
procureur national anti terroriste nous
savons que c'était une attaque d'une
extrême violence
donc après avoir tué deux personnes
l'auteur s'est rendu dans un bureau
voisin où il a poignardé à plusieurs
reprises
un autre fonctionnaire qui était un
adjoint administratif présent et
plusieurs coups lui ont été portés qui
sont avérés être des coups mortels
il a ensuite tenté de poursuivre son
périple au sein du service dans un autre
bureau et qui était fermée où se
trouvaient trois agents et puis il s'est
dirigé vers la cour de la préfecture de
police la cour d'honneur en croisant
dans l'escalier une jeune me gardienne
de la paix de la death pape de la
direction de la sécurité de la propre
site de proximité de l'agglomération
parisienne qui l'a également donc tuer
ou en utilisant son arme son couteau et
poursuivant son périple vers la cour il
a blessé grièvement une eau un autre
agent administratif une jeune femme qui
travaille à la direction des ressources
humaines de la préfecture de police
c'est une fois qu'il est arrivé dans la
cour qu'il a été donc abattu grâce au
courage et à la détermination et
sang-froid d'un jeune gardien de la paix
non nous avons un nombre de nombreuses
reprises rencontré avec le ministre
d'ailleurs qui avait qui étaient en
poste depuis six jours il sortait de
l'école et qui alertés par d'autres
personnels donc c'est porter au devant
de l'agresseur lequel est venu dans sa
direction menaçant couteau à la main et
donc il a été il a été abattu
voilà je joue il était important de
revenir sur ces faits très rapidement
sachant qu'ils ont duré et là encore le
procureur l'a bien précisé une durée
totale de 7 minutes
merci messieurs les ministres
je vais sans plus attendre donner la
parole aux collègues qui l'ont déjà
demandé d'abord monsieur françois noël
buffet merci monsieur le président
messieurs les ministres
ma question porte principalement sur la
thématique de l'habilitation au secret
défense et les conditions de celle-ci
nous savons que cet habit cette
habitation pardon secret de la défense
nationale a été réformé en 2011
je rappelle que la durée des méditations
sont assez longues en fait dix ans pour
le confidentiel défense ces sept ans
pour le secret défense et 5 ans pour le
très secret défense
or nous savons tous que les
comportements individuels peuvent
évoluer que la radicalisation
naturellement on peut se tenir dans un
délai extrêmement court
mais question sujet de questions en
réalité la première c pensez vous que
cette périodicité des enquêtes
d'habitation
est-elle suffisante ou insuffisante nous
pensons qu'elle est insuffisante mais
nous souhaiterions votre point de vue là
dessus et ne sera-t-il pas envisageable
voire même très souhaitable de prévoir
des enquêtes aléatoire en cours
d'habilitation voir une enquête
intermédiaire obligatoire pour tous les
personnels habilités occupant des postes
de nature stratégique
en clair peut-on intensifier le moyen de
contrôle auprès des personnels en
matière d'habitation
merci messieurs les ministres l'un de
l'autre
merci monsieur le président d'abord dire
deux choses il y à l'ensemble des
personnels du ministère de l'intérieur
des fossés que de l'intérieur qui font
l'objet d'une attention sur les risques
de radicalisation ont peut-être
l'occasion de reparler mais c'était dans
le sens aussi des questions plus globale
du président philippe bas et ensuite il
y effectivement la question de
l'habilitation ça a été réformé en 2011
je le dis dans un contexte qui
effectivement était différent c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous travaillons
depuis quelques mois déjà une révision
globale du système de l'habilitation et
à un référentiel qui pourrait être
différent à la fois dans la triple
classification est à la fois aussi du
coup dans la durée mais je crois que le
débat n'est pas forcément alors d'abord
je le redis 2011 un contexte totalement
différent oui
en 2011 on décide de rallonger la durée
et si j'avais été en responsabilité
dominance je pense qu'avec le regard de
celui ou celle qui a porté cette
prorogation j'aurais certainement fait
la même chose je préfère le préciser
parce que quand on fait référence à date
on peut penser qu'il s'agit de montrer
tel ou tel nom parce que le contexte
était différent
ensuite il faut avoir en tête que healy
a effectivement cette habilitation quand
on rentre dans le dispositif du secret
défense
puis la régularité et ensuite il peut y
avoir à tout moment en fonction
d'indicateurs qui permettent de
déclencher a eu une alerte une nouvelle
vérification et donc vous en proposer de
une à travers les enquêtes aléatoire
pourquoi pas je pense que c'est un vrai
sujet parce que ça peut permettre aussi
de mettre une pression collective sur
l'ensemble du dispositif une sur des
rendez vous réguliers mais surtout je
crois que ce qui est fondamental d'avoir
en tête c'est que nous devons pouvoir
identifier pour nos agents
au sens large et en particulier pour les
agents habilités au secret défense et en
particulier pour ceux qui sont au sein
du renseignement
tous les signes d' alerte non nous
pourrions avoir connaissance alors j'ai
bien noté que kan devant les
parlementaires les députés de la
commission des lois
j'ai donné la liste de ce qui peut
permettre d'identifier une
radicalisation notamment vers un islam
radical
l'islam politique et vers le terrorisme
un certain nombre de personnes se sont
moqués en le reprenant un parent en
disant hashtag désigne-t-on musulmans
chacun ici c'est que personne ne fait de
lien entre la religion musulmane et le
terrorisme ni même entre la religion
musulmane la radicalisation et le
terrorisme mais cela peut arriver et
donc le nier ce serait mentir aux
français
et j'ai bien noté qu' à partir des
signes que j'avais indiqué certains ont
glosé ou même fait de l'humour
je trouve ça méprisable méprisable
justement parce que j'en appelle et
c'est la première mesure que j'ai prise
à l'ensemble de nos fonctionnaires de
police à être eux mêmes acteurs du
signalement ce qui s'est passé laurent
l'a abordé rapidement parce que nous
voulions plutôt répondre à vos questions
que de refaire tout ça c'est que
effectivement dans le cas de l'auteur de
l' attaque et je ne la qualifie pas
autrement je laisserais au procureur
national anti terroriste le soin de dire
le droit sur ce sujet mais dans le cadre
de l' attaque ce que l'on a vu ce qui
nous est remonté notamment dans un
rapport administratif dont j'ai eu à
demander dont j'ai eu connaissance
dimanche c'est que il y a eu des signes
de radicalisation qui n'ont pas été
interprétée au bon niveau et qui n'ont
pas fait l'objet du signalement
nécessaire et donc j'ai demandé à
l'ensemble de nos forces comme le préfet
de police qui l'a fait par note a
demandé à l'ensemble des agents la
préfecture de police de faire en sorte
que tous les signes a relevé le soin et
fassent l'objet d'un signalement
ça ne veut pas dire s'il ya des signes
qui lie à radicalisation mais c'est
l'analyse de ceux dont c'est la
responsabilité et nous avons partout
dans notre dispositif des personnels qui
ont été formés à la détection de la
radicale des gens c'est l'analyse de
l'ensemble de ces dispositifs
alors on s'est moqué je vais le redire
dans ces signes il y a le port de la
barbe il ya le refus de serrer la main à
des collègues féminines
il y a
le fait de présenter une hyper kératoses
au milieu du front c'est la tabac chacun
le sait il y a le prosélytisme religieux
intempestifs il ya la consultation
frénétique de sites religieux depuis son
poste de travail
il a la fréquentation notoire de
personnes radicaliser il ya le port d'un
voile intégral sur la voie publique pour
un fonctionnaire fait mine ce sont des
éléments qui peuvent après analyse
caractérisé la radicalisation et donc
c'est à partir pour répondre précisément
à votre question
à partir de ces éléments là qu'on doit
pouvoir alerter faire un signalement à
tout moment il faut qu'à tout moment on
puisse voir l'évolution d'un agent dans
le cas présent de l'auteur en 2003 aucun
signe en 2013 au moment de du
renouvellement de son habilitation aucun
ci n'apparaît et puis ensuite il ya des
signes qui ont pu apparaître j'ai
connaissance nous avons connaissance de
signes en 2015 il y en a peut-être une
autre ensuite l'enquète le dira et c'est
signe là n'ont pas provoqué le bon
niveau d alerte au bon endroit pour
faire en sorte non pas de sanctionner
cet agent mais de vérifier si
effectivement il y avait une
radicalisation
si c'était le cas de lui parler ce sont
les consignes de l'igpn de prendre
d'abord le temps d'échanger de rappeler
ce qui doit être au coeur de
l'engagement de fonctionnaires le
principe de laïcité qui est le coeur de
notre engagement est qu'est notre
feuille de route que nous devons mettre
en oeuvre pour vérifier cela
et s'il y avait effectivement des
anomalies à ce moment là je n'hésiterai
jamais à sanctionner et 6 lits à une
radicalisation forte à utiliser tous les
process dont nous disposons qu'ils sont
nombreux pour provoquer une éviction de
cette agence un dos aux postes de
responsabilité a fortiori s'il est dans
le renseignement
2 de la fonction publique du ministère
de l'intérieur si les radicaliser je
crois
monsieur le ministre on peut être mettre
ensemble que l'islam est une religion
mais que l'islamisme radical est une
idéologie politique extrémiste et qui
peut conduire dans certains cas jusqu'à
l'action terroriste et donc il est
parfaitement légitime pour la république
d'administrer un traitement différent
d'une part religion et d'autre part aux
doctrines qui sape les fondements mêmes
de notre constitution je crois que
c'était état d'esprit aujourd'hui
et bien compris l'application du
principe de laïcité à l'islamisme
radical n'est pas une démarche
pertinente
ce qui est pertinent c'est d'appliquer à
l'islamisme radical
les dispositions qu on pourrait
appliquer pour tout mouvement politique
visant à remettre en cause les droits
fondamentaux
la primauté de la loi de la république
sur toutes autres règles et si on a
nommé ça et qu'on appelle clairement ce
que sont nos principes et nos valeurs je
crois qu'on aura déjà un peu progressé
je voulais faire cette observation que
je crois vous partager et qui nous
éloigne un peu du coeur du dispositif de
sécurité que nous devons examiner
ensemble
mais ces principes communs je crois
qu'il est important de les rappeler
nous avons actuellement treize demandes
de parole mes chers collègues nous
devons terminer impérativement à 10h30
j'ai donc donné une première fois la
parole aux présidents sueur qui l'a
demandé les ministres répondrait
répondront aux de manière aussi concise
mais nécessairement précise que possible
et puis ensuite je serai amené à grouper
les questions de manière à gagner un
petit peu de temps monsieur président
sueur qui monsieur le président cette
nuit plusieurs commissariats de police
paris ont reçu des enregistrements
faisant l'éloge
des attentats de 2015 eu quelque
information avez-vous là dessus et y at
il des liens possibles avec ce qui s'est
passé de la semaine dernière
deuxièmement il a été question d'une clé
usb
retrouvez dans le tiroir de l'assassin
cette clé usb comporter de la propagande
pour du jihadisme violent et un certain
nombre de noms de fonctionnaires de la
police et des services de renseignement
avec des coordonnées
il a été dit monsieur le ministre que
ces clés usb ne posait pas de problème
particulier qu'il n'avait pas été
diffusé en êtes vous sur quels moyens
avez-vous de vérifier que ces noms n'ont
pas été diffusés
troisième et dernière question monsieur
le premier ministre a annoncé deux
enquêtes pour faire en sorte que ce qui
s'est passé ne se renouvelle pas ce qui
s'est passé c'est finalement que au
coeur du réacteur de la lutte contre le
terrorisme
c'est à dire les sept services de
renseignement qui existe dans notre pays
au coeur de ce réacteur au coeur du
coeur des personnes une personne a pu se
radicaliser préparer et mettre en oeuvre
un acte terroriste
quels moyens concrets allez vous mettre
en oeuvre dans les jours et les semaines
qui viennent pour vérifier que cela ne
peut pas se reproduire et donc procéder
aux examens nécessaires dans l'ensemble
des services de renseignement à cet
égard je vous savez qu'il existe un
service national des enquêtes
administratives de sécurité celui ci est
des îles a pour objet de vérifier que le
comportement des personnes n'est pas
incompatible avec l'exercice des
fonctions notamment dans le domaine du
renseignement
il est doté de 23 agents et cinq
réservistes
vous avez annoncé qu'il allait passer à
60 9 agents pouvez vous le confirmer et
nous dire à quelle date cela sera
effectué et quelles mesures très
concrètes seront prises pour faire ce
que vous venez de l'annoncé à monsieur
buffet les signalement obligatoire
seront ils écrit c'est à dire il y aura
t'il l'obligation pour les agents qui
auront ces informations d'en faire part
à leurs supérieurs de manière écrite je
précise et j'arrête là messieurs les
ministres
les sujets sont larges monsieur le
président sur d'abord votre première
question effectivement plusieurs
commissariats ont reçu des
enregistrements qui pourrait paraître
menaçant je mets cela au conditionnel
non pas sur le fait qu'ils aient reçu
mais sur l'interprétation des messages
le préfet de police a immédiatement
porté plainte pour qu'une enquête se
dérouler pour que nous puissions
comprendre cela je vous dirais hélas
c'est un phénomène que nous connaissons
à chaque fois qu'il ya un événement
particulier il ya ce genre d'initiative
totalement abruti qui sont réalisés vous
savez qu'on a service national le cna
père qui travaille sur les signalements
de ce type là il se trouve que chaque
fois qu'un événement il ya une hausse
significative des appels téléphoniques
et des envois de formulaires
juste pour illustrer rapidement le jeudi
3 octobre le sénat p r a été appelée à
11 reprises
là durant le week-end il est reçu 23
appelle le samedi et le dimanche et
lundi il a reçu 40 appels que nous
instruisons de la même façon de toute
façon mais ça rend un peu l'exercice
plus compliqué voilà que ce que je veux
vous dire sur ce premier volet il ne
suscite pas d'inquiétude outre mesure
surtout que rien n'établit au moment où
je vous parle qu'il y aurait une
organisation collective autour de
l'auteur de l'attentât c'est la seule je
dis bien rien établi au moment où je
vous parle mais aucun indice n'est
apparue sur ce sujet même si je n'ai pas
accès aux éléments de l'enquète s'il y
avait des alertes vous le savez dans le
cas de l'an
être sur tel ou tel risque évidemment le
procureur national anti terroriste nous
indiquerait qu'il faut protéger tel ou
tel sujet à risque sur la clé usb
d'abord je voudrais vous rappeler qu'on
est dans le cadre du secret de l'enquêté
donc nous n'avons pas accès à cela mais
surtout et c'est pas bout que je dis ça
par rapport à votre question je voudrais
rappeler la responsabilité morale de
ceux qui propagent des rumeurs et qui
inquiète inutilement
dans ce dossier on a dit tout et
n'importe quoi dès le début ça a
commencé par le fait qu'au moment de la
perquisition l'épousé était en niqab
ça a commencé par toute une série
d'informations le concernant qui étaient
toutes fausses
y compris sur cette clé usb ou un grand
journal national a sorti cette affaire
en dix ans la clé usb a été trouvée à
son domicile ce qui effectivement serait
une première anomalie
la clé usb est et trouvait à son bureau
ce qui pour un informaticien et je ne
dis pas qu'elle n'est pas grave mais ce
qui pour un informaticien chacun sait qu
on a l'habitude sur certains types de
clés usb de vider la centrale de leurs
d'un ordinateur sur lequel on intervient
ça ne veut pas dire qu'elle n'est pas
grave je n'ai aucun élément sur ce sujet
là mais je nous invite à ne pas porter j
invite la presse à ne pas porter des
rumeurs qui inquiète inutilement sur
cela en gros ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que aucune alerte particulière ne
tourne autour des dossiers qui sont
actuellement placés sous l'instruction
mais ça ne veut pas dire qu'il n'ya pas
de risque et deuxièmement que sur le
contenu de la clé usb tout ce qui est
sorti dans la presse me semble éloigné
de la vérité de toute façon n'est pas
confirmé le préfet de police a quand
même réuni hier un chsct avec les
organisations syndicales pour évoquer
cela outre la crise profonde que
traverse la préfecture de police
les inquiétudes légitimes des agents
dont les noms pourraient être divulgués
nous voulons pas la mettre en cause et
est du coup il faut nous protège et
voyez ce que je veux dire sur la clé usb
certains éléments de l'enquète ne nous
emballons pas sur ce sujet mais hélas je
ne suis pas en mesure de vous dire si le
terroriste a diffusé des informations
vers l'extérieur ou pas même si nous
n'avons pas d'élément particulier sur ce
sujet qui nous alertent pense être clair
troisième question sur les deux enquêtes
de l'insee
je vous rappelle que l ont été demandés
par le police qui est compétent sur les
sr sur l'ensemble des services de
renseignements liés au terrorisme
pas seulement sur le ministère de
l'intérieur et elles visent un double
niveau d'abord au sein de la préfecture
de police
au sein du service de renseignement
faire en sorte de voir ce qui a
fonctionné et ce qui a dysfonctionné
faire en sorte de constater si tous les
process ont été mises en oeuvre
et quand les process n'ont pas été mises
en oeuvre pour quoi et ça il est demandé
qu avant le 12 novembre d une vision
précise sur ce sujet là pour adapter
notre dispositif même si je voulais dit
le préfet de police a dès le lendemain
le lundi pris une circulaire interne
pour appeler l'attention sur la bonne
utilisation du process tel qu'il existe
aujourd'hui et son renforcement et une
deuxième enquête plus global qui a une
double vocation d'abord nous aider avec
vos travaux parlementaires à avoir la
photographie globale de faiblesse
possible dans le service du
renseignement mais qui a aussi une
finalité qui n'a peut-être pas été assez
perçu il est demandé en gros aux
inspecteurs de descendre à tous les
niveaux de la hiérarchie pour faire un
travail de sensibilisation en be to be
avec les différents niveaux de
hiérarchie sur le fait que rien ne peut
être considéré comme anodin même si
c'est anodin
il faut qu'on puisse analyser le
caractère anodin ou pas c'est très
compliqué parce que c'est la
subjectivité humaine parce que nos
services de renseignement sont composées
de femmes et d'hommes avec forcément une
part de subjectivité mais aussi avec une
sacrée expérience
et c'est sur cette expérience là qu'il
faut construire notre appréciation de
savoir si on doit déclencher quelque
chose où paraît donc oui les
signalements les signaux faibles
quel que soit le à ce niveau de
responsabilité je parle pas de la
société en général mais ces signalements
doivent être faits et doivent être
construits comme cela je vais laisser
laurent lyonnaise poursuivre sur le
renforcement du sneaa c'est sur cette
dimension jeux sont peut-être des
signalements et la forme des
signalements
oui je vais vous répondre sur les deux
les deux dernières qui si on vous avait
posé la première sur le cinéaste la
seconde effectivement sur la forme que
doit revêtir ce signalement sur le sneaa
rapidement vous savez je pense toutes et
tous que ce n'est as a été créé dans la
foulée de la loi dite loi savary qui
avait créé des criblage ou imposé des
criblage avant recrutement d'un certain
nombre d'agents dans le domaine des
transports puis ça a été étendue aux
grands événements et puis le sénat ça
maintenant en charge le lait criblage
avant recrutement notamment des
policiers des gendarmes et d'un certain
nombre de catégories pop professionnels
dont les policiers municipaux certains
agents de sécurité privée donc son champ
d'action da cessé d'augmenter et les
choses vont sans doute se poursuivre
puisque dans la foulée le du rapport
diard pouya comme vous le savez nous
travaillons à la mise en oeuvre nous pas
d'un certain nombre de mesures dont
l'extension éventuelle des criblage de
la même façon que va être mise en oeuvre
la loi citée notamment son article 114 1
qui prévoit la possibilité de faire ce
qu'on appelle des rétros criblage et qui
vaudront bien évidemment pour les
policiers les gendarmes sur cette
possibilité une fois recruté une fois un
service lorsqu'il apparaît un
comportement qui n'est plus compatible
avec l'exercice de la mission
la possibilité de re procéder à un
criblage le syneas a accès l'ensemble
des fichiers qui nous permettent de
détecter des anomalies
donc ça aussi c'était un élément de
réformes important que cette cette
consultation possible dans des
conditions bien évidemment tu as fait
encadrer de ces fichiers l'objectif donc
pour répondre clairement à votre
question après avoir planté ce décor
l'objectif c'est d'avoir un cinéaste qui
soit 67 agents à la fin de l'année 2020
ont donc actuellement ce sont une
trentaine d'agents et donc le service va
monter en puissance sur la forme du
signalement vous avez raison monsieur
monsieur monsieur le sénateur sueur
d'insister sur le ce signalement qui
christophe castaner l'a rappelé il est
fondamental ce signalement notamment
notamment dans les services de police
d'abord parce que il déclenche la
saisine des cellules d
et qui sont notamment chargés de suivre
la radicalisation dans l'eau service
on y reviendra sans doute qui est très
faible très très faible donc c'est
important saisine de cette cellule qui
est sous qui est auprès de l'igpn
pour ce qui est de la police nationale
et auprès d'un service dédié de la
gendarmerie nationale avec les jets
peine pour les gendarmes deuxièmement ce
signalement mais il va comme l'a rappelé
tout à l'heure le ministre permettre de
réexaminer de revisiter l'habilitation
de déclencher de nouvelles enquêtes
d'habilitation qui s'il signalement la
radicalisation et confirmés se
traduisent au bio obligatoirement par le
retrait de la méditation et
troisièmement bien évidemment quand il y
un signalement de radicalisation il ya
un service de renseignement qui
généralement rentrer en jeu et prend en
charge
l'individu donc je signale ans il est
fondamental le ministre a rappelé à
l'instant l'inspection les services de
renseignement va justement avoir pour
objet devoir de vérifier service par
service
comment sont traitées ces signalements
comment ils remontent et surtout donc de
sensibiliser les personnels à l'est
notamment la hiérarchie de ses
personnels à la nécessité absolue
d'avoir un signalement nous n'avons pas
encore déterminé encadrer la façon de
savoir si seulement il doit être écrit
ou oral la seule chose que je peux je
peux dire c'est que y compris un
signalement khalil doit être pris en
compte quand il est grave et doit être
pris en compte
ça c'est voilà la forme du signalement
est un peu ce n'est pas l'élément le
plus déterminant si vous me permettez
cette réflexion un signalement orale
il doit être pris en compte nous verrons
ce que nous déciderons à une fois que
l'inspection des services de
renseignement se sera prononcé sur ce
sujet sur imposé ou pas un caractère
écrit mais
le plus important pour nous franchement
c'est que l'information elle circule
qu'elles soient prises en compte
ah bon niveau et donc voilà sur le
signalement écrit où nous verrons avec
avec le ministre de l'intérieur suite à
la halle aux travaux prendront rapport
que londres à l'inscription des services
de renseignement mais voilà le deuxième
au rallye doit être pris en compte a
fortiori un signalement écrit c'est
quand même beaucoup mieux
pardon monsieur le président si vous
plantez juste un mot pour l'information
les sénateurs en parlant de du
recrutement hostias je veux évoquer les
1900 recrutement que nous faisons dans
le quinquennat pour renforcer les
services de renseignement avec un
problème et c'est celui que je voudrais
évoquer devant vous c'est la capacité
que nous avons à recruter les bonnes
personnes au bon endroit sur les sujets
aussi sensibles
si nous ouvrons des postes de gardiens
de la paix ce que nous faisons chaque
année dans le cadre du plan de
recrutement de dix mille policiers et
gendarmes supplémentaires nous avons des
candidats des jeunes français et des
françaises motivés qui viennent sur les
candidatures pour le renseignement il
nous faut un niveau de compétence qui
est différent et nous connaissons une
difficulté sur ce sujet sur lequel nous
travaillons en particulier avec le
directeur général de la sécurité
intérieure pour nous donner les moyens
d'attractivité supplémentaire
voilà ce que je voulais préciser sur sur
cela et est un mot sur la forme des
signalements il ya aussi les supports de
signalement n'a été interpellé sur la
question d'une plateforme sur la
question de l'anonymat
l'anonymisation ce sont des sujets que
nous n'excluons pas sachant qu' il
s'agit pas de délation
il s'agit d'informations auprès de
quelqu'un qui est spécialement formés
pour analyser les signes d'une
éventuelle radicalisation un complément
vraiment sur la nature du signalement
vous dire le laisse idéalement c'est
quelque chose qu'on connaît bien
puisqu'on travaille depuis 2014 sur des
dispositifs qui ont été mis en place
sous le quinquennat précédent que nous
avons poursuivi renforcée est
actuellement les signalements
de la radicalisation dans l'ensemble de
la population dans l'en se fait ailleurs
que dans les services régaliens pardon
ils ont ils revêtent plusieurs formes
ce qu'il compte c'est qu'il y ait une
cellule un service dédié qui le
formalise lui paraît clé mais le
signalement il peut prendre plusieurs
formes d'ores et déjà sachez le monsieur
le secrétaire d'état vous avez évoqué il
ya un instant le rétro ciblage criblage
c'est un dispositif qui est prévu par la
loi sur la sécurité extérieure et la
lutte contre le terrorisme qui est
entrée en vigueur le 1er novembre 2017
et vous avez dit je vous cite que vous
travaillez à la mise en oeuvre de ce
dispositif pourquoi est-ce que c'est
seulement maintenant qu'on y travaille
alors que la loi a été promulguée il ya
deux ans d'abord c'était un dispositif
qui donc pour que vous compreniez bien
le jeu on parle bien du rétro criblage
donc dispositif qui permet donc de re
crible et des agents de souveraineté
essentiellement par des agents qui sont
dans les services de régalien de manière
à le cas échéant détecté une anomalie
parce que on aura observé un
comportement de cette personne qui
attire l'attention et qui laisse planer
un doute sur la compatibilité entre ce
comportement et l'exercice de missions
notamment de souveraineté de missions
régaliennes donc
la conséquence parce que c'est ça qui
est important c'est que dans le texte de
l'article 114 1 bien sûr on peut
procéder à des rétro criblage et ça
c'est pas vraiment l'objet du thé avec
l'objet du texte surtout c'est de
prévoir des mesures qui permettent
d'écarter l'agent de ses missions en
dehors du contexte disciplinaire que
nous utilisons actuellement et pour ce
faire il ya un certain nombre de mesures
qui sont des mesures fortes qui
nécessite la mise en place d'une
commission qui émet un avis et c'est
cette commission qui doit être mise en
place pour que le texte trouve
pleinement à s'appliquer et la parution
de cette instruction est imminente mais
une fois que je vous ai dit ça ne perdez
pas de vue que dans les services
régaliens
nous travaillons déjà à la détection de
rades de cas de radicalisation
actuellement ont suivi on va dire une
vingtaine de personnes dans la police
nationale une dizaine dans la
gendarmerie nationale c'est très peu
mais nous y travaillons et nous écartons
d'ores et déjà ces personnes de leur
activité simplement
simplement nous utilisons tout le toutes
les mesures que nous permettent le droit
disciplinaire qui permet d'écarter ses
agents et nous pouvons même aller et ça
s'est effectivement produit jusqu'à la
révocation
voilà donc il y a deux dispositifs
parallèle l'aurait trop criblage c'est
quelque chose qui est très importante
bien sûr très attendu mais en attendant
nous avons grâce au droit disciplinaire
la possibilité d'agir et c'est ce que
nous faisons merci de ces précisions
il nous reste mes chers collègues 40
minutes donc je vais vous demander
de regrouper vos questions par groupes
de trois les ministres y répondrons ça
veut dire que puisque là encore douze
demandes de parole il faut s'en tenir à
des interventions aussi sobre et
consiste possible et les ministres même
veillerons à ce que au fond chaque bloc
de questions ne fassent pas l'objet d'un
des changes
au total de plus de 10 minutes je donne
la parole successivement à madame de la
gontrie à monsieur grosdidier et à
monsieur du ramadam de la gontrie vient
d'être évoqué la question du rétro
criblage et ce qui est très troublant en
fait dans les explications qui sont
données
c'est une forme de décalage entre les
ambitions annoncées d'une extrême
vigilance sur la situation des agents et
la réalité de ce qui est opéré le
président bâle a rappelé c'est une loi
du 30 octobre 2017 qui prévoit de mettre
en place lorsque cela s'avère utile le
rétro criblage nous sommes deux ans plus
tard et pourtant ce dispositif n'est
toujours pas mis en place ce n'est pas
faute d'ailleurs que vous ayez été
interpellé sur ce sujet par des
parlementaires
c'est donc un premier exemple est une
première curiosité et lorsque j'utilise
terme curiosité je suis en dessous de ce
que je pense de la même manière un
deuxième exemple vous avez monsieur le
ministre pris le 13 novembre 2018
une circulaire qui avait vocation à ce
qu'il y ait un échange avec les maires
concernant les difficultés éventuelles
présenté par tel ou tel agent d'une
commune vous aviez dans cette circulaire
demandé aux préfets de rendre compte
dans les trois mois de la mise en oeuvre
de ces échanges
il s'avère que pour la commune que je
connais le mieux savoir la ville de
paris cela n'a jamais été mis en place
malgré la demande de la mère de paris
si je point de cela c'est parce qu'il y
a donc cette impression et j'en aurai
thériault de décalage entre les
intentions louables voir les lois votées
et la réalité de ce qui se fait sur le
terrain qui amène à ce que de ce fait un
grand nombre de situations n'ait pas été
prise en compte et du coup parfois les
drames que nous avons connue et donc sur
ces deux sujets j'aurais aimé que vous
puissiez nous éclairer merci cher
collègue monsieur grosdidier
si si oui je partage totalement les
réflexions à l'analyse de notre
président philippe bas donc je ne
répèterai pas mais ça fait des années
que la république paraît avoir toujours
un temps de retard avec l'ennemi dans
cette guerre qui je vous l'accordé d'un
nouveau type donc il ya beaucoup de
choses à changer dans tout ce qu'on a
toujours fait vous l'avez évoqué leur
monsieur ministe dans la détection des
comportements et des attitudes
individuelles
il ya beaucoup d'autres points réforme
et je me limiterai à 2 contre une
alimentation de saintes paroles premier
point la révocation des fonctionnaires a
fortiori des policiers militaires
islamistes salafistes et potentiellement
jihadistes paradoxalement vous pouvez
enlever l'habilitation un agent de
sécurité privé provoquant son
licenciement alors faudrait-il changer
la loi pour que vous puissiez révoquer
un fonctionnaire à la lumière des
informations des services de
renseignement
et pareil pour un maire notamment pour
les agents de police municipale et
pouvoir faire partager par le juge
administratif les informations des
services de renseignement
à condition bien sûr qu'ils en gardent
le secret le deuxième point c'est
l'anachronisme de la préfecture de
police de paris
elle est la survivance d'une époque
jusqu'à vichy où les polices urbaines
était sous l'autorité des maires puisque
c'était le cas sous tout un troisième
république donc la pp se justifie t'elle
encore en dehors de la dèche epn et
surtout son service de renseignement en
dehors de la dg et si vous avez
pourfendu la réforme sarkozy du
renseignement justement le seul à y
avoir échappé et précisément
le service de renseignement de la
préfecture de police
franchement qui est toujours sur le
modèle des vieux rg de papa donc
franchement n'est-il pas temps de briser
les cloisonnements dans nos forces
merci cher collègue monsieur du rhin
monsieur le ministre nous comprenons
parfaitement les obligations de
protection de la confidentialité de
l'enquète qui sont les vôtres
pour autant nous aurons besoin et dont
revendiquant un droit à l'information
plus exhaustif possible pour forger nos
propres réflexions il ya un élément qui
pourrait nous aider c'est sans doute de
nous voir communiquer la fiche de poste
de michael harpon pour comprendre les
missions qu'ils étaient chargés
d'exécuter deuxième question on voit qu
une réflexion globale a porté sur
l'organisation de la police et des
services de sécurité il y avait un
organe pour cela une institution
l'institut des hautes études de la
sécurité intérieure et la justice que
vous avez choisi de supprimer
est-ce qu'on n'a pas besoin d'un peu de
profondeur un peu de une base arrière
théorique qui fonde les réflexions sur
l'organisation et quelle est
l'alternative à cet institut des hautes
études de la sécurité intérieur et
justice que vous avez choisi le
supprimer messieurs les ministres
pardon c'est à présent je vais redire ce
que l'euro nasa dit on répondra marie
pierre de la gontrie et et nous ferons
ça va devoir en essayant d'être rapide
je vous le dis madame la sénatrice
pleurait trop pliage rétro criblage
existe et fonctionne je ne veux pas vous
laisser dire ni même pensé que depuis
deux ans il n'existerait pas il existe
et il fonctionne il faut avoir en tête
qui lie à l'habilitation et ensuite il y
a 6 des vulnérabilités apparaissent la
possibilité de contrôler à tous les
niveaux le principe même de
l'habilitation c'est que d'abord il ya
une enquête un questionnaire une enquête
un peu administrative mais de toute
façon le contenu de la quête est très
variable
il reste à l'appréciation du seul
service enquêteur s'il ya un niveau
d'inquiétude le service la dg ainsi par
exemple peut permettre d'organiser un
entretien de sécurité avec le candidat
s'il ya une alerte supplémentaires on
peut utiliser toutes les techniques de
renseignement
on va consulter évidemment tous les
fichiers mais on va utiliser tous
les techniques de renseignement qui sont
à la disposition de nos services
encadrés par la loi et nous pouvons
parfaitement organisée le rétro clivage
selon on parle et je voudrais quelque
chose soit claire c'est uniquement la
question qui était organisé par article
l 114,1 de pouvoir se séparer et donc
révoquer un agent du ministère de
l'intérieur par exemple en cas de
radicalisation pourquoi nous ne l'avons
pas utiliser parce que jusqu'à présent
nous n'en avons pas eu besoin et je vous
le dis il y a à peu près un portefeuille
qui n'a jamais dépassé une trentaine de
signalements au sein de la police
nationale qui est suivi par l'igpn
dans ce portefeuille là il y a des gens
dont on considère qu'il ya des éléments
qui caractérisent le fait qu'ils sont
radicalisées sur lequel il faut engager
une procédure est plutôt que de
s'enfermer dans une seule disposition
notre administration et jeudi notre
alimentation au sens large parce que ça
remonte à 2015 notre administration a
fait le choix d'utiliser tous les moyens
possibles pour écarter l'argent et dans
notre cas présent ils sont aujourd'hui
dans ces agents qui sont suivis 19 je
vous ai parlé d'une trentaine de
signalement d'une quarantaine en tout et
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya une vingtaine
de personnes qui nous ont quittés voilà
je peux donner quelques exemples ça peut
être une mise à disponibilité pour une
création d'entreprise ça peut être des
révocations dont une actuellement est
suspendu un jugement au fond ça peut
être un licenciement
si on est avec des ads ça peut être une
déclaration d'inaptitude professionnels
ça peut être le non renouvellement d'un
contrat d'adr ça peut être une fin de
stage parce qu'on a eu d'éclats sur des
fans de sachets donc je vous le dis
notre administration
elle veille à utiliser tous les moyens
possibles et si nous avions besoin dans
un mois d'utiliser la procédure qui est
prévu par l'article l100 14
nous aurons les moyens d'utiliser dans
un mois sans difficulté voilages insiste
sur ce sujet ne cherchons pas à nous
opposer sur sûr cela nous savons
rétro-club et dans le cadre légal et
nous le faisons et nous avançons sur ces
sujets sur les échanges avec les maires
je veux pas me prononcer sur la mairie
de paris en particulier mais j'ai signé
cette circulaire d'information des mères
j'ai voulu que les maires soient au
coeur de la prévention de la lutte
contre la radicalisation leur donnant un
certain nombre d'éléments
encore faut-il et je ne parle pas pour
la mairie de paris encore faut-il que
les maires le demande
la proposition du préfet et accepte et
je ne veux pas parler de la mairie de
paris en particulier mon propos se veut
générale et politique surtout dans un
contexte de proximité municipal et je
n'ai aucun sujet là dessus encore
faut-il que les maires acceptent aussi
de rentrer dans cette logique et
notamment la charte de confidentialité
et je vous le dire on a hélas
quelquefois des mères qui ne rentre pas
dans ce dispositif là et donc c'est une
fragilité aussi mais nous avons mis en
place le dispositif qui permet un maire
d'avoir une information sur une personne
radicaliser travaillant dans un service
sensible qui permet au maire d'avoir un
retour systématique sur ces signalements
et s'il ya un dysfonctionnement à la
mairie de paris
je propose c'est qu' une réunion
spécifique sur la mairie de paris sur ce
sujet là mais je vous invite à garder la
dimension nationale de nos réflexions se
grosdidier
oui on a un temps de retard avec
l'ennemi quand on est frappé par ce
qu'on parle évidemment de ceux qui nous
frappent
mais je l' ai dit tout à l'heure nos
services et jeudi nos services parce que
j'en fais pas un cocorico personnes se
seraient totalement vulgaire nos
services
tous les jours on est en avance sur la
nuit tous les jours mais évidemment ils
ne sont pas à 100% on l'a vu jeudi
donc il nous faut être meilleur sur ce
sujet là j'ai répondu à la question de
la révocation d'un fokker on n'a pas
besoin de changer la loi
aujourd'hui pour les agents de la police
nationale de la gendarmerie nationale
c'est un peu différent mais du coup
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas forcément de
besoin si au terme de la revue que nous
engageons on voit qu'il ya besoin de
d'affiner d'améliorer ou de changer des
choses je vous promets que je viendrais
volontiers m'appuyer sur le sénat pour
avancer sur ces sujets pour les mesures
d'ordre législatif
juste sur la préfecture de police
d'abord moi j'ai jamais pourfendu la
réforme sarkozy c'est pas le sujet ce
que je veux dire c'est que il y avait un
dispositif sur les agréments au secret
défense qui n'était pas suffisamment
encadré à la préfecture de police
nous avons fait signer un protocole
entre la dg à six et la préfecture de
police en février 2019 pour que
justement on rentre dans le cadre
référentiel national pour que je ne veux
pas reprendre vos mots mais les vieux
hergé à la papa que vous avez dit soit
le qualifie pas le seul os et services
ainsi mais voilà soit encadrée et donc
oui et d'ailleurs ça a été dit notamment
dans une audition qui a fuité par la
responsable de ce service du
renseignement à la préfecture de police
elle a précisé cela elle a pris les
choses en main on a aujourd'hui un
dispositif est un référentiel qui est
similaire à celui là dg acier qui est
placée sous le contrôle de la dg à 6
ensuite l'ensemble des signalements sont
étudiées par jessy 12 ans
je suis trop longues sur le présent je
suis je suis désolé je crois qu'on doit
pouvoir on va vérifier vous communiquer
la fiche de poste de l'auteur on va
vérifier
voilà les noms et les classifier elle
est forcément classifiés avec touche à
l'organisation donc et puis elle est
mondiale enquêtes en cours mais tout ce
qui touche à l'organisation des services
de renseignement sont classifiés donc on
peut qu'on pourra pas vous la communauté
non vous savez ce qu'on a à faire on va
la communiquer à la mission la
délégation ardennaise
et comme le président en est membre il
portera votre voix sur ce sujet voilà ce
que je propose
voilà ensuite sur les évolutions
administrative et la suppression d'un
sound beaufils
je crois que je me sens en prendre
autant sur lignes j et on n'est pas
aujourd'hui sur ce sujet là vraiment et
si jamais il y avait un risque en le
supprimant sur notre capacité d'analysé
nous ne le supprime ne devrions pas et à
la verse
si son existence garantissez contre le
risque terroriste nous l'aurions su donc
voilà ce que je vais vous dire une
phrase sur ce dernier sujet le depuis
l'élection du président macron a été
réactivé redynamiser la coordination
nationale au renseignement
nous avons le secrétariat général
également au comité du comité
interministériel de prévention de la
délinquance et de la radicalisation dont
l'objectif est de s'ouvrir au monde de
la recherche pour enrichir notre
réflexion et si à la fois le cnra lite
est à la fois le cicr il travaille
travaille avec de nombreux chercheurs et
donc les choses se passent bien et voilà
nous nous prenons totalement en compte
cette dimension qu'on ne peut pas
analyser commenter à la seule au seul
sort d'un institut merci messieurs des
ministres madame benbassa monsieur le
ministre mon collègue sueur a déjà parlé
disney a semé moi je voudrais ajouter
quelques éléments vous vous vous êtes
fixé comme objectif d'atteindre
d'atteinte 69e agents d'ici à 2020 et
cela est bien évidemment insuffisant si
l'on met ce chiffre en perspective avec
les cinq millions et demi de
fonctionnaires que compte notre pays
ainsi monsieur le ministre prévoyez-vous
d'accroître considérablement le
personnel et les moyens de ce service
est ce que le gouvernement envisagerait
d'étendre son champ d'action à tous les
services publics puisque la
radicalisation ne concerne pas seulement
la préfecture ou le ministère de
l'intérieur
et j'ajouterais
une autre petite question quand on
octroie et une habilitation pour accéder
au secret défense on examine
l'environnement donc la famille le
conjoint etc est l'auteur de la tuerie
de la préfecture s'est marié en s'est
remarié en 2014
et cela n'a pas déclenché un nouveau
contrôle pourriez vous nous donner
quelques éléments de réponse sur cette
question également je vous remercie
merci cher collègue madame eustache
brinio monsieur nice moi je voudrais
revenir sur le discours du 8 octobre à
la préfecture de police du président la
république qui a affirmé et l'idée de
bâtir ensemble une société de vigilance
et a appelé à lutter contre l'hydre
islamiste
sauf que cette hydre islamistes il ne
l'a pas défini je voulais savoir si dans
l'esprit du président il incluait les
frères musulmans les salafistes
wahhabites tous les courants extrémistes
qui font de l'islam doctrine politique
et religieuse donc je veux savoir le
smic
concrètement ce qu'envisage le
gouvernement pour traduire rapidement et
concrètement cette ses actes en volonté
de la volonté présidentielle puisque si
on ne nomme pas les choses on ne peut
pas évidemment les remettre en cause
donc je voudrais voir concrètement
comment cela va se valider dans les
faits merci merci chers collègues de
votre précision monsieur alain marc
merci président messieurs les ministres
certaines informations ont été
rapportées qui font état de
fonctionnaires de police à la préfecture
de police affectés à la lutte
antiterroriste et si je dis cela
aujourd'hui c'est parce que j'étais au
courant mais un journal national s'en
est fait l'écho et ayant accès à des
données sensibles comme le fit jet qui
est le fichier judiciaire automatisé des
auteurs d'infractions terroristes se
personnes converties à l'islam a fait
l'objet de plusieurs signalements écrit
ainsi que d' enquête administrative car
ils présentaient des signes de
radicalisation islamiste
lorsqu il y à des signalements écrit
même si vous
dit que je n'avais finalement pas eu une
importance considérable comme ce fut le
cas
vos services et procède-t-il à des
enquêtes systématiques et ses enquêtes
englobe est elle aussi l'entourage très
proche du fonctionnaire radicaliser
comment peut-on expliquer que ce
fonctionnaire était est maintenu à un
poste aussi sensible
malgré les signalements et enquête et se
pose ce fonctionnaire est il toujours en
poste aujourd'hui
ensuite deuxième question le président
de la république lors de son
intervention à la préfecture de police a
parlé de vigilance en l'opposant aux
soupçons
comment protéger vous les personnes à
l'origine de signalement de
radicalisation islamiste qui souvent
sont dissuadés d'alerter leur hiérarchie
par ken par crainte d'être accusé
d'islamophobie
merci chers collègues messier des
ministres alors je commence sur le
cinéaste fallait qu'un est question dans
l'âme la sénatrice benbassa donc sur le
syneas l'objectif n'est pas à ce stade
de cribler l'ensemble des fonctionnaires
à on se concentre sur ceux qui exercent
des missions de sécurité ou pour
d'autres professions que les
fonctionnaires ce qui touche à des
questions de sécurité
c'était d'ailleurs l'objet à l'origine
de la loi savary sur les personnels ils
travaillaient dans les transports et qui
était en charge de missions de 2
sécurité et donc la cible la cible c'est
quand même d'être en capacité avec
l'effectif que j'ai rappelé tout à
l'heure de pouvoir procéder en 2021 à
environ 3 millions d' enquêtes annuelles
ce qui est quand même un niveau assez
significatif est donc l'objectif cible
je le redis 1,67 à jean donc à la fin de
2020 et ce qui nous semble suffisant
pour rassurer donc les contrôles tels
qu'ils sont prévus
deuxième question l'extension
l'extension elle est proposée dans le
rapport diarrhée poulat qui propose
d'étendre le criblage à un certain
nombre de catégories professionnelles
nous avons plusieurs réunions alors je
les cite par exemple les personnes qui
sont en contact de la petite-enfance les
personnes qui sont en contact avec des
personnes vulnérables et donc là nous
avons une série de réunions
interministérielles et donc sont à
l'étude
les des textes pour étendre le cas
échéant les compétences du cinéaste
voilà ce que je peux dire sur le
cinéaste vous vous êtes vous interroger
sur le une vous aviez une troisième
question pardon sur le contrôle qui
aurait dû être fait en 2014 au moment du
mariage de l'auteur de l'acte alors
attention donc quand on quand il ya donc
le mariage effectivement il en disant
les choses dans l'ordre c'est un
événement nouveau qui justifie que l'on
regarde à nouveau le dossier
d'habilitation bien évidemment y compris
lorsque cette habilitation est en cours
on n'attend pas le renouvellement mais
un mariage ne justifie pas forcément que
l'on fasse une enquête d'habilitation
qu'ils soient poussées avec les enquêtes
d'habilitation revêt plusieurs formes ça
va du criblage ça peut aller du simple
criblage jusqu'à l'entretien individuel
voir et c'est prévu par les textes
l'utilisation de techniques de
renseignements au cas d'espèce un
mariage ne suffit pas forcément a
déclenché une enquête d'une telle
intensité
pour compléter avec deux questions qui
se recoupent un peu qu'ils sortent aussi
seulement du sujet de l'examen pour le
secret l'habilitation défense et pour
nos fonctionnaires et je prends en
faisant attention toujours à bien
distinguer cela il s'agit pas
aujourd'hui de mettre en place un
dispositif de criblage pour l'ensemble
de la fonction publique française
à moins qu'il y ait une décision
politique qui relèvera du parlement de
le faire mais je crains van hamme la
sénatrice que vous puissiez nous le
reprocher si je suggéré de passer au
crible la totalité des fonctionnaires de
france je suis pas sûr par exemple que
dans l'éducation nationale ça ne
provoque pas quelques tensions et donc
il est important d'avoir en tête que
nous devons avoir le bon niveau
d'information mais pas rentrer dans une
société du contrôle absolu mais je pense
que c'est le c'était pas le sens de
votre question mais en même temps vous
avez cité un nombre de fonctionnaires
qui ne correspond pas forcément à ceux
qui aujourd'hui sont considérés par nos
interventions
mais la question se posera parce que le
risque peut exister il ya la question de
la forme d'information sur un risque et
donc sur le caractérisation de la
radicalisation
je pense qu'il faut que nous avancions
vers la forme la plus neutre possible
pour ce qui concerne les services de
police je considère que c'est la
responsabilité d'un policier ou d'un
gendarme d'assumer la dénonciation de
phénomènes de radicalisation qu ils
constateraient et pour moi ce n'est pas
négociable
ça fait partie de leur mission ils
doivent protéger les français ils
doivent protéger leurs collègues et je
refuse qu'ils me posent une réserve sur
ce sujet là mais nous devons quand même
prévoir la possibilité de les protéger
et la façon de les protéger c'est qu'ils
vont voir le référent en charge la
radicalisation qu'ils échangent avec lui
qui n'a pas besoin laurent nunez va
rapper il n'a pas besoin d'avoir un
signalement écrit pour prendre la
décision d'aller un peu plus loin dans
les investigations
et je pense que c'est ce système là qui
doit être fiable dans le cas qui nous
concerne ce qui s'est passé c'est
qu'effectivement il y a eu des signaux
qui ont été considérés comme de faible
intensité il ya eu des discussions et
quand le responsable en charge la
radicalisation a dit est ce que vous
faites ainsi allemand est ce que vous
voulez qu'on s'en charge
en gros ils ont répondu selon ce dont je
dispose d' enquête administrative qui
m'a été remontés ils ont répondu non
se trouve qu'il ya quelques semaines
encore le responsable
un des responsables en charge de ces
sujets est repassé dans le service en
question est à poser la question comment
ça se passe bien se trouve qu' il ya
quelques semaines encore dans ce service
quand on organisait un pot tout le monde
était invité et on faisait attention à
ce qu'ils aient pas de porc parce que le
fait qu' un des membres du service soit
musulman était connu et donc on
respecter cela voilà le problème que
nous avons eue c'est que l'on n'a pas
considéré à ce moment là que les
éléments étaient suffisants or s'il ya
vu cette information plus une note plus
une autre et peut-être que l' enquête
pourra montrer qu'il y avait d'autres
éléments qui pourraient caractériser la
radicalisation
à ce moment là nous aurions peut-être pu
éviter ce qui s'est passé
plus globalement madame la sénatrice
vous m'interrogez sur la lutte contre la
radicalisation et l'islamisme politique
et je pense qu'il faut nommer les chats
comme ils sont et donc il s'agit
vraiment de mener une action déterminée
contre toutes les formes de
radicalisation et en particulier l'islam
politique
il ya des outils dont nous disposons
depuis 2014 la création du fsb rt la loi
renforçant la sécurité intérieure lutte
contre le terrorisme d'octobre 2010 est
le plan d'action contre le terrorisme
qui est adoptée le 13 juillet 18 la
coordination entre services renforcée
par la création du cnr ltée est le chef
de file est la dg assis et le plan de
lutte contre la prévention de la
radicalisation qui est élaboré le 23
février 2018 l'idée c'est d'intervenir y
compris ceux par territoire territoire
par territoire où on voit qu'on a des
écosystèmes qui se crée il ya la mosquée
il ya l'association et à l'école ya le
commerce il ya tous ces dispositifs
c'est de donner la main aussi aux
territoires avec tous les acteurs pour
intervenir
j'ai évoqué hier on répondra au psg des
chiffres que nous n'allions pas
communiquer jusqu'à présent mais dans le
cadre des plans de lutte contre
l'éradication dans les quartiers depuis
février 10 829 débits de boissons
étaient fermés 12 lieux de culte ont été
fermés 2 dans le cadre de la loi citée
je précise cette différence pour vous
dire que la loi s'il talent cadre le
dispositif
lié à un prosélytisme religieux mais
nous avons d'autres moyens de faire
fermer des lieux de culte et nous le
faisons neuf établissements culturels
associatifs ont été fermés quatre écoles
ont été fermées 503 contrôle codaf ont
été réalisés et deux chiffres 2.5
millions d'euros redressée par l'acap
12,2 millions d'euros dressé par
l'urssaf
je cite ces deux chiffres pour vous dire
que on veut intervenir de façon la plus
large possible pour que effectivement on
ne laisse pas s'organiser un écosystème
qui porte cette radicalité et cette
radicalisation politique et il ya un
combat qu'il nous faut mener
c'est celui de la lutte contre
l'évitement scolaire dans certains
quartiers que nous suivons un
particulier sous l'autorité du préfet
frédéric rose d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
auprès de moi dans certains quartiers où
on peut voir les évolutions on a des
indicateurs qui évolue bien sûr les
formes de violence sur le chômage etc
par contre un des indicateurs qui évolue
mal c'est sûr la déscolarisation des
enfants
ça c'est une alerte sur un phénomène de
radicalisation dans un quartier contre
lequel nous devons lutter et donc c'est
vraiment nous armer et nous armé
moralement parce que y compris cette
polémique que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
sur le fait que je dise il peut y avoir
des signes de radiation et qui est des
gens qui trouvent utile de faire des
blagues de faire un hashtag sur ce sujet
qui ne me touche pas personnellement
montre bien qu au fond c'est peut-être
aussi dans nos esprits qu'il faut qu'on
arrive à s'éveiller
c'est bien sûr un vrai risque notre
société face au terrorisme mais aussi
face à l'islamisme politique fasse assez
radical juin notre société courent un
risque
j'assume de vous le dire politiquement
et donc il nous faut aussi nous réarmer
c'est ce à quoi nous invite le président
de la république selon merci monsieur
que l'on bat monsieur le ministre je
vous avoue qu'il ya une chose qui
m'étonne c'est que dans l'impression que
dans votre arsenal il ya ya ya rien n'y
a pas d'intervention possibles lors
d'une procédure disciplinaire mais
pourquoi ne serait-il pas possible pour
des raisons de service de
de neutraliser un individu dont on a
quand même des signes qui a manifesté
quand même des signes assez clair et
assez nette de radicalisation je suppose
que le service dans lequel il était qui
est un service sensible n'est pas le
seul qui ait besoin d'informaticiens ça
ça n'existe plus donc la raison de
service il sans donner d'explication
particulière sans flétrir quelqu'un sans
le désigner enfin etc
mais là il n'était pas n'importe où
c'est et j'élargis ray la question en
disant moi depuis donc que les des
attentats les vagues d'attentats en
particulier fin de fin 2013
on a passé son temps ici à durcir le
code pénal a autorisé les moyens des
moyens d'investigation parfois contre
contestable généralisée enfin etc
et il semblerait qu'il n'y a pas de ce
qui s'est passé au niveau 2 du services
centraux est ce qu'il ya eu une
réorganisation est ce qu'il ya eu la
mise en place seulement pas de trahir
des secrets mais on a l'impression que
tout ça est resté immuable
je sais pas je suis un peu comme ça un
peu curieux alors où je pense que je
dois me tromper complètement et que vous
allez me dire vous allez maintenant me
rassurer je suis pas inquiet mais merci
merci cher collègue monsieur président
caennais merci monsieur présents
philippe bas 2013 donc monsieur mickaël
larpe on a eu sa nouvelle habilitation
secret défense 2013 pour sept ans vous
avez parlé de monsieur le ministre
castaner de failles de faiblesse le mot
de fautes n'a pas été utilisé y at il eu
une faute dans les services de la drpp
pour cette forme d'autocensure qui
aboutit aux conséquences mortifères que
nous connaissons il y a maintenant une
semaine
est ce que le faisceau de présomptions
qui était évident ne devait pas être
mise en exergue plus rapidement et
directement je vous pose une question y
at il d'autres
mickaël larpe on aujourd'hui dans la
drpp madame billère b et ont gagné un
deuxième monsieur le président quelles
sont les mesures éventuelles de
prévention en termes d'intégrité
physique ou comptait prendre pour les
fonctionnaires qui ont été retrouvés en
termes de fichage dans la clé usb de
monsieur mickey leur poids merci
monsieur président madame l'herbe y est
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
secrétaire d'état on a parlé de deux
signalements ont il semblerait que dans
l'état actuel mais notre droit on
dispose les moyens pour écarter un
fonctionnaire de police de son poste
mais je voudrais revenir sur l'ensemble
de des autres des autres institutions
imaginons que un signalement de
radicalisation de
d'une personne susceptible dangereuse
soit soit effectué dans un hôpital ou
dans un univers cité c'est quand même le
ministère de l'intérieur qui est le
regard
au terme de ce signalement de l'état de
dangerosité de ce fonctionnaire alors je
voudrais savoir si les juridictions
administratives sont associés à cette
réflexion générale que nous avons tous
parce que quand on passe un concours
quel qu'il soit on est protégé par ce
concours est pour être évoquée en quoi
que ce soit il faut vraiment des preuves
et des preuves
solide est ce que à l'heure actuelle
l'état du droit peut être amélioré en la
circonstance je vous remercie chaque
collecte mais si les miss plusieurs
questions portait sur une préoccupation
la présence éventuelle dans des services
de sécurité d'autres agents radicaliser
qu'on n'aurait pas encore détecté ou
même ton suspecterait déjà de
radicalisation et dont certains auraient
pu être muté dans un autre service
je me souviens de la question tout à
l'heure de monsieur à la marque qui
faisait état de la mutation d'un
fonctionnaire dans un service support
comme si tous les services support au
sein de nos services de renseignement
étaient des services qui n'étaient pas
exposées à des risques d'insécurité
donc compte tenu de certaines
informations qui ont été diffusées dans
la presse une mise au point me paraît
devoir s'imposer de votre part
à cet égard et je crois que la réponse à
la question précise de monsieur marc n'a
pas été apportée tout à l'heure tout
donne la parole
donc je vais répondre au monsieur le
sénateur colombes arbre sur la procédure
disciplinaire je pense qu'on a répondu
sur comment on procède pour écarter les
fonctionnaires des services de sécurité
voilà le on vous a clairement répondu
sur ce point on utilise donc la
procédure disciplinaire en attendant
d'avoir un texte mais nous sommes nous
sommes
oui j'y vis j'y lis j'ai bien compris
j'ai bien compris monsieur collomb bas
il existe ce que l'on bat seul le
ministre à la parole pour lui résiste il
existe à la jeu je vous raconte je vous
réponds de nouveau ce que l'on bat je me
répète je vais rajouter un élément
puisque vous avez cité 7
cette procédure quand il y a des
détections de radicalisation dans les
services publics dans l'administration
auprès des forces de sécurité intérieure
le cas est traité analyser on évalue
cette radicalisation si elle est réelle
il y à des mesures qui surprise et on
utilise encore une fois toutes nos
possibilités il peut y avoir la
procédure discipline
c'est une possibilité il peut y avoir
également et vous l'avez site est
effectivement ce que vous avez appelé la
mutation dans l'intérêt du service qui
existe également qui peut être utilisé
et il ya surtout pour parlons bon à côté
monsieur colombages je reprends ce qu'a
dit christophe castaner est ce que nous
avons dit tous ces jours derniers il y a
pas eu de signalement claire explicite
il n'y a eu dans cette affaire
au vu des informations qui sont en notre
possession à ce stade des échanges oraux
de fonctionnaires qui n'ont pas été
confirmées il n'y a pas eu de
signalement formaliser et c'est bien si
vous me le permettez le drame de ce
dossier si ça avait été le cas et je
croyais pourtant l'avoir dit je le redis
la cellule de l'igpn auraient été saisis
une nouvelle enquête d'habilitation
aurait été diligentée qui aurait permis
de révéler un certain nombre de choses
il retirait son son habilitation est un
service de renseignement auraient été
saisis pour suivre cette personne sur la
réorganisation des services centraux
vous dites monsieur qu collombat qu'en
matière de lutte antiterroriste
l'organisation est immuable pardon c'est
totalement faux depuis l'arrivée du
président macron il a instauré il a
obligé contraint les services de
renseignement à être en permanence en
échange d'informations il a créé un état
major permanent particulier qui existe
au sein de la dg six qui réunit tous les
services de renseignement tous les
services judiciaires en charge la lutte
antiterroriste avec des outils dédiés
qui échangent en permanence
d'information traite les objectifs sur
les partages et il n'y a plus il n'ya
plus de pardon de le dire mais nous
n'avons plus les guerres de services
auxquels nous avions pu assister par le
passé et ça c'est une réorganisation
fondamentale
je poursuis peut-être sur le oui je vous
prenait l'envié sur sur les signalements
ça permet de clarifier les choses vous
avez donné un exemple qui est la
fonction publique hospitalière c'est un
exemple mais il y en a d'autres
le dispositif de signalement dans ce
pays il a été organisé à partir de 2014
puis les montées en puissance il revêt
plusieurs formes
il ya un numéro vert qui existent où on
peut on peut appeler est tombé sur un
être être écouté par référent de l'ucl
atteint d'une unité de coordination de
la lutte antiterroriste
on peut signaler tout
sun radicaliser de la même façon qu'il
existe dans chaque structure des
référents radicalisation des formes les
personnages ont leur on l'est on les
informe sur le fait qu'il doive quand il
constate chez un agent un de leurs
collègues de leurs subordonnés ou voir
un supérieur hiérarchique
quand ils constatent des signaux de
radicalisation ils doivent s'adresser à
ce référent et ça ce sont les ars par
exemple dans les hôpitaux qui diffuse
cette information et ce signalement
ensuite est portée à la connaissance
dans tous les départements des
préfectures
il y à des analyses qui sont faites par
les services du renseignement
territoriales pour confirmer il pas
cette radicalisation et quand elle est
confirmée
l'individu est pris en charge par les
services de renseignement qui utilisent
leur technique de suivi habituel et ça
c'est un dispositif non alors j'y viens
le signalement on arrive au signalement
est donc l'individu est pris en compte
et quand la radicalisation est confirmée
il ya deux types de mesures
il ya les mesures qui sont prises en
interne et qui permettent de prendre un
certain nombre de décisions de gestion
mais il ya aussi les mesures qui peuvent
être prises par les services de
renseignements vous imaginez bien qu'on
y vient d'individus qui tombe dans la
radicaliser la radicalisation et la
radicalisation violente peut être pris
en compte et y compris d'ailleurs au
plan judiciaire mais voilà le système de
signalement il existe et nous nous
assurons de son correct fonctionnement
partout sur l'ensemble du territoire
national fait juste quand même
pardon je veux pas montrer inutilement
insistant mais une question précise et
poser un commandant de police qui est
radicalisée qui seraient affectés dans
un service qui s'occupe de fichiers de
la délinquance de la criminalité du
terrorisme est ce que c'est quelque
chose qui vous paraît acceptable
et est-ce que ça a eu lieu puisque
nous avons tous vu des informations de
presse faisant état de cette éventualité
répondre très précisément à votre
question nous avons vu comme vous ces
informations de presse c'est un dossier
qui n'est pas connu et sur lequel nous
avons demandé une enquête immédiate
flash pour comprendre mais pour répondre
précédant votre question si ces faits
étaient avérés évidemment la réponse est
non à votre question précise donc nous
n'avons pas répondu parce qu'il s'agit
d'une personne qui est dénoncée entre
guillemets par la presse nous n'avons
pas ce niveau d'information mais nous
avons évidemment c'est considéré qu'il
fallait une enquête sur ce sujet je
pourrais peut-être vous communiquer mais
à vous monsieur le président sans
difficulté je pense
les éléments que nous aurons sur ce
sujet là que les choses soient très
claires mais nous ne sommes pas ici pour
relayer et d'ailleurs je le dis au
président caennais je pense avoir
répondu sur la clé usb vous me posez la
question de dire qu'est ce qui a été
fait pour les fonctionnaires qui ont été
retrouvés sur la clé usb vous affirmer
quelque chose dont j'ai dis
qu'aujourd'hui je n'avais pas
connaissance et donc je ne répondrai pas
à cette question parce que ce serait une
façon de relayer le fait que comme la
presse l'a dit il y aurait une liste de
fonctionnaires qui seraient menacés ça
n'est pas au moment où je vous parle
caractérisé ça n'est pas exclue et je
nous invite à ne pas alimenter cela de
la même façon monsieur collombat est ce
que vous pensez une seconde que qui que
ce soit dans la hiérarchie de cet
individu qui aurait eu connaissance de
ces faits là ne se serait pas dit tiens
il faut peut-être le changer de service
et donc je voudrais que les choses
soient très claires
d'ailleurs on a beaucoup évoqué les
propos que j'ai tenus ce jour là j'ai
tenu des propos de vérité la vérité des
collègues de bureau avec lesquels j'ai
pu discuter l'après midi la vérité du
dossier administratif de cet agent la
vérité de nos fichiers divers et variés
la vérité de la dg ainsi que nous avons
consultés sur ce cas là cet individu
n'était au moment où j'ai parlé connu
sous aucun signe de radicalisation parce
que personne en 2014 en 2015 mais
monsieur collombat ça s'appelle une
enquête judiciaire et donc lankais du
monsieur collombat s'il vous plaît je
trouve franchement
ce petit procès n'ont pas à moi mais aux
gens qui n'auraient pas désigné de mes
jeux mais monsieur voulons bas je vous
le dis les gens qui n'auraient pas
désigné pour prendre une décision
administrative pour muter un agent dans
notre pays dans notre état de droit et
je pense que vous y tenez il faut des
éléments ces éléments ne sont pas
remontés et c'est pour ça que j'ai parlé
de failles mais je n'ai pas parlé de
faute et je réponds aussi à monsieur k
nerfs parce que c'est à la justice aux
enquêtes de dire s'il ya eu faute ou pas
ce n'est pas au ministre
je ne pense pas que ce soit aussi au
sénat de désigner les fautes quand elles
sont individuelles mais s'il en quête
inverse qu'il y à des fautes évidemment
elles devront être corrigés quand on
parle de fonctionnement global
sanctionné s'il ya des fautes
individuelles mais le moment où je vous
parle il est nécessairement consacré à
la correction d'un système qui doit
protéger qui doit protéger les français
qui doit protéger nos fonctionnaires et
il ya eu cette question que vous avez
repris monsieur le président de ba
existe-t-il éventuellement d'autres
agents qui corresponde à ce type là
personne ne peut vous dire droit dans
les yeux
non monsieur le président il ya personne
qui correspond à ce profil là ce que je
sais c'est qu'au moment où je vous parle
il ya une quarantaine de cas de signaler
dans la police nationale j'ai évoqué les
différentes formes les différentes
formes compte utiliser pour les écarter
dont la mutation je réponds encore un
monsieur collombat dont la révocation et
je voulais d'ici cas de révocation était
engagé une est suspendu en référé devant
le tribunal
et donc nous utilisons tous les moyens
pour éloigner ou écarter ces
fonctionnaires je veux que les choses
soient très claires il en reste dix neuf
selon les chiffres qui m'ont été
contactées qui ont fait l'objet d'un
signalement mais dont les autorités ont
considéré que le signalement n'était pas
caractéristique d'une radicalisation et
là aussi c'est important d'assumer cela
et je les assume
c'est pas parce que quelqu'un marque un
signe de conversion religieuse par
exemple qu'il est forcément radicaliser
et qui doit forcément être écartée mais
si par contre il est sur un poste
sensible je pense qu'il ne faut pas
hésiter
il faut un dialogue avec l'agent épais
mais c'est pour ça que quand mais je
peux vous dire que sur les dix neuf ont
été identifiés sur lequel
les dossiers sont remontés nous avons
pratiqué effectivement des mutations
voire même des mutations hors périmètre
police parce que nous savons aussi faire
cela tout joué que les choses soient
claires de façon systématique quand il
ya le bon niveau d'alerté
aujourd'hui il y à une enquête ensuite
elle se base sur une appréciation
humaine elle peut commettre une erreur
c'est la vérité de notre société il faut
l'assumer
moi je ne connais pas aujourd'hui de
logiciels qui pourrait passer au
criblage 5 millions de fonctionnaires et
qui pourrait nous dire voilà celui qui
doit rester là et qui doit faire cela
c'est une forme de société qui
techniquement n'existe pas et
politiquement ne me convient pas mais
nous devons de façon impérative de façon
systématique chaque fois qu'il y a des
formes de radicalisation au sein de nos
services
comme dans notre société lutter contre
et les neutraliser une ome de choses
merci messieurs les ministres monsieur
fichés oui merci monsieur le président
messieurs les ministres une première
question un peu d'ordre général il ya eu
un rapport sénatorial en 2016 et de
l'assemblée nationale en 2019 sur la
notion de service public radicalisation
et dans les deux cas les rapporteurs
s'interroge sur la notion de
radicalisation et est-ce que de votre
côté vous avez aujourd'hui une
définition plus précise de ce qu'est la
radicalisation
la deuxième question rapidement tous les
éléments relatifs aux signes d'une
radicalisation uniquement fait l'objet
de discussions entre membres du service
mais non banque fait l'objet de rapports
écrits ni d'inscription au dossier
administratif
aujourd'hui les syndicats de police nous
disent voilà nous on est prêts
effectivement à s'engager dans cette
procédure un petit peu de signalisation
mais cependant on souhaiterait couvert
juridiquement donc ce qui nécessiterait
effectivement une procédure législative
est ce que de votre côté vous êtes prêt
à engager une telle procédure pour
couvrir les signalements faits par les
agents des services et des
des cas merci merci de cette question
chère collègue madame jourdain
merci monsieur le président messieurs
les ministres une une question sur
l'application de la loi s'ils que nous
avons à plusieurs reprises évoqué cette
loi permettait d'une part de réaliser
des enquêtes administratives dont j'ai
compris qu'elle était réalisée et
d'autre part d'éloigner une personne qui
présentait des signes de radicalisation
dont j'ai compris et que cette procédure
n'avait pas été mise en oeuvre et que la
même surprise je dirais que le président
bas et que madame de la gontrie
pour autant vous nous avez indiqué que
le droit commun si je puis m'exprimer
ainsi permettait néanmoins d'écarter
soit au sein d'un service soit en dehors
de l'administration une personne qui
présentait des signes de radicalisation
ces personnes font elles l'objet d'un
suivi et si oui lequel
monsieur richard l'expérience indique
que même la perspective de prendre une
décision de sanction ou de mutation
d'office légal conduit bien des
dirigeants est rare chica hésité parce
que vous savez bien que la perspective
de voir cette décision finalement annulé
quatre ou cinq ans après à l'issue de
trois degrés de juridiction est un frein
très fort
nous allons avoir deux rapports
d'inspection sur ces fêtes et sur les
situations rencontrées dans les services
je pense qu'il serait judicieux que dans
un de ses rapports soient analysés les
facteurs constaté de réticence ou
d'hésitation à prendre les décisions
suivant l'expression de la jurisprudence
en considération de la personne et que
soit suggéré un guide juridique claire
qui permettent aux personnes qui sont
dans les premiers niveaux de préparation
d'une telle décision de sanctions de se
sentir plus assurée merci chers
collègues de deux dernières questions
celle de monsieur wattebled puis de
madame delattre monsieur waterblez
monsieur le ministre monsieur sera delta
je pense qu'il faut prendre le mal à la
source et la propagande de l'islamiste
radical se fait soit par les réseaux
sociaux ou soit par certaines crèches on
apprend que l'assassin de nos quatre
agents étaient en contact avec annie un
imam radicaliser fichiers et qui devait
être expulsé du territoire
pourquoi ne l'at il pas été fait ça elle
n'a pas été fait et en plus ma deuxième
question serait quand il du contrôle des
imams radicaux qui sont en place et
aussi le recrutement des futurs imams et
scan yeux directives données
j'aime bien c'est très délicat c'est un
2ème religieux mais cette surveillance
puisque aussi le mal bien par là merci
cher collègue madame delattre
si monsieur le président merci messieurs
les ministres effectivement nous ne
sommes pas là pour faire prospérer des
rumeurs mais je pense que nous avons
besoin d'éléments complémentaires pour
mieux comprendre un collègue nous
demander la possibilité d'avoir la fiche
de poste
effectivement était possible de savoir
quel type de données avait axé sur quels
types de données avec ses sept agents s
qui lui a été possible d'effacer des
données sur des personnes pour protéger
des fichiers s par exemple ou d'autres
données sensibles
je repose la question c'est vrai que
sans alimenter la rumeur de la clé usb
il avait accès à des noms au delà du cst
que le préfet a pu conduire hier
vous en avez informé est ce que ces
personnes font quand même l'objet d'une
protection particulière
ensuite pour complémenter la question de
donner dany wattebled
est-ce que effectivement sa femme a
échangé des sms avec lui on l'a appris
par les journaux
elle a été elle n'est plus sous
surveillance est ce que vous avez pu
avoir un contact avec l es ce que vous
avez une surveillance particulière par
rapport à cette personne et puis on le
sait il côtoyait des salafistes
etait-il fichier s est ce que c'est
quelque chose que vous pouvez
effectivement nous dire où ces personnes
font elles l'objet aujourd'hui d'une
surveillance très étroite merci
messieurs les ministres
donc la première question c'est celle de
la définition de la radicalisation je
crois donc mollard des questions à ce
sujet il ya plusieurs choses à d'abord
il ya la radicalisation dit violente qui
qui peut conduire à des actions
violentes qui peut ce défi ça peut être
de l'apologie du terrorisme ça peut être
un soutien aux actions ça peut être des
contacts avec des individus qui sont
engagés dans la radicalisation violente
l'adhésion au djihad va donc ça bien
évidemment vous imaginez bien que ce
genre d'individu été immédiatement pris
en compte par les services de
renseignement tout comme le sont
d'autres formes de radicalisation qui
peut ne pas prôner l'action violente de
manière explicite que c'est un nombre
d'individus qui peuvent ne pas prôner
l'actionnaire ne pas forcément être en
contact avec des individus qui y eu même
sont suivis au titre du terreau du
djihad août l'adhésion aux terreaux donc
qu'ils sont dans une pratique rigoriste
de l'islam et nous considérons bien
évidemment que c'est une forme de
radicalisation
chaque fois que cette pratique en vient
à considérer en vient à considérer que
finalement la loi de dieu peut être
supérieure aux lois de la république ça
se traduit par des phénomènes qu'a
rappelé le ministre de l'intérieur de
phénomènes de déscolarisation
ça peut être des phénomènes
comportementaux et qui sont
effectivement d autant de signaux qu'il
faut absolument prendre en compte et
c'est une définition que nous prenons
évidemment content je crois que le
ministre l'a rappelé il ya on a bien on
a bien deux deux branches bien
distinctes
la radicalisation violente qui peut qui
s'affiche d'emblée comme étant une
adhésion aux actions violentes
un soutien aux actions violentes parfois
même une participation ça c'est une
chose c'est ce que font les services de
renseignement qui suivent un certain
nombre d'objectifs
et puis il ya toute cette prise en
compte de cet islam politique de cette
forme de communautarisme qui fait qu'à
un moment on considère que la loi de
dieu est encore une fois supérieur de la
république et c'est ce que nous prenons
en compte le ministre l'a rappelé c'est
le suivi que nous faisons d'un certain
nombre de lieux de culte de lieu de
rassemblement de clubs sportifs les
contrôles qui sont effectués dans les
écoles hors contrat et bien évidemment
des mesures administrées
yves qui s'en suivent et qui se
traduisent ici par des fermetures la
part des contrôles par tous moyens à
notre disposition contrôles fiscaux
contrôle urssaf
autant d'actions que nous menons pour
déstabiliser cet islam radical des
derniers points pour répondre à votre
question sur les signalements les
policiers je ne crois pas que les
policiers craignent de procéder a dit
ces diamants de collègues qui soit à
radicaliser je partage ce que disait
tout à l'heure christophe castaner moi
je n'y crois pas une seconde
mais ça vaut pour les policiers et les
gendarmes en tout état de cause et je
veux le redire ici et tout le monde le
sait les signalements en tout état de
cause ils peuvent parfaitement être
anonyme ça n'est pas le sujet où peuvent
parfaitement être anonyme
c'est ce qui se passe avec le numéro
vert qui est mis à disposition de la
population pour signaler des individus
radicalisés dans l'ensemble de la
population
les signalements sont anonymes donc mais
en tout état de cause je ne veux pas
croire que les policiers aient peur
souhaite être couverts juridiquement et
de protéger je pense qu'il ya une grande
responsabilité chez eux
merci j'ajoute que je n'invite pas les
fonctions de la police qui constate des
signes à penser qu'ils doivent passer
par les syndicats pour le faire parce
que ce n'est pas le rôle des syndicats
et je ne dis pas ça contre les syndicats
mais je pense que ça n'est vraiment pas
leur rôle
c'est pas nécessaire de mettre un nouvel
élément dans la boucle un signalement de
se faire directement aux personnes qui
sont compétentes et notre système est
organisée pour qu'on ait des
responsables du suivi radicalisation
partout deuxième élément de réponse à
madame jourdain pour la troisième fois
je veux bien que vous ayez la même
surprise donc je vous ferai la même
réponse que la troisième fois nous avons
révoqué ses agents nous n'avons pas
utilisé le dispositif elle 114,1 parce
que nous n'en avons pas eu besoin
alors je veux bien que on alimente un
procès sur mon dieu ça avait été mise en
place
nous ne l'avons pas mis en place parce
que nous n'en avons pas eu besoin
et si nous enlevons nos besoins nous le
mettons en place voilà je pense qu'il
faut être clair et pas cherché à
polémiquer sur ce sujet mais je voulais
10,6 révocation ont été engagés dans la
police est pas dans le cadre depuis 2015
et pas dans le cadre de ce dispositif
avant et après voilà je voudrais être
très clair sur sur ce sujet 10e en 10
secondes compléter ce que vient de dire
le mise
l'intérieur parce que c'est aussi une
question vous avez posées bien
évidemment cette fonctionnaire qui fait
l'objet des mesures mais bien évidemment
qu'il est pris en compte par les
services de renseignement voilà bien sûr
d'abord voilà il y compris quand il est
à l'extérieur du service cet individu
des mesures ont été prises parce qu'on a
considéré qu'il était radicaliser donc
il devait faire l'objet d'attentions et
forcément il est suivi par les services
de renseignement et peut-être même
inscrire vos fesses pertes et et je
voulais 10 19
prenons 1er juin 19 sont suivis
particulièrement je n'en dirai pas plus
mais ils le savent aussi
il est bon qu'il le sache deuxième
élément on peut avoir une réflexion plus
globale et c'est l'intérêt aussi des
discussions que demain ce matin sur le
fait de savoir si le motif de
radicalisation pourrait susciter pour
l'ensemble des fonctionnaires un motif
de révocation
moi je vous le dis je trouverai pas
illégitime qui est ce débat parce que je
pense que la fonction publique doit
incarner une forme d'exemplarité sur un
le respect de toutes les valeurs de la
laïcité dans son comportement de le
respect des valeurs de la république ou
la verse
il n'y a pas de hiérarchie entre le 1 et
le 2 et que du coup je pourrais
considérer que ce débat une forme de
légitimité politique à être posés pour
l'ensemble de la fonction publique parce
ce qui a été prévu dans le texte que
vous avez voté porte effectivement sur
nos policiers sur nos gendarmes et pas
surtout les gendarmes d'ailleurs sur ce
sujet voilà
mais c'est un propos politique que je
vous tiens sur sur cela pour répondre à
alain richard la lutte contre la
régulation doit conduire à écarter les
fonctionnaires vraiment et évidemment
sur d'une façon ou d'une autre mais vous
l'avez dit moi j'étais plus loin en
évoquant la révocation qui pourrait être
élargie mais c'est une discussion
politique je nous annonce pas une mesure
gouvernementale je préfère que les
choses soient claires mais évidemment ça
ne s'arrête pas comme vous l'avez dit à
se disputer faisait pour ça que j'ai
rappelé et que nous aurons porter une
attention particulière à la question du
sénateur que l'on va on a rappelé qu'on
utilisait
tous les moyens pour éloigner le
fonctionnaire qui vont de la rade delà
du refus d'agrément par exemple d'une
fin de stage jusqu'à la révocation
la radicalisation et pour répondre à
votre deuxième question est une dérive
violente et l'objectif est bien de le
contenir et de le combattre avec des
mesures de surveillance individuelle
nous le faisons mais aussi la
judiciarisation et c'est notre objectif
d'avancé sur la judiciarisation jeu
watts b sur l'imam c'est compliqué pas
le dossier
mais c'est compliqué parce que il ya
d'un côté la focalisation sur cette
personne dont je ne sais pas au moment
où je vous parle s'il ya un quelconque
rapport avec l'en quête dont on parle
en cela c'est compliqué parce que moi je
veux bien que la presse désigne des gens
comme responsables coupables et
qu'ensuite on en parle en boucle pendant
va je vous reproche pas votre question
je vais répondre mais mais voilà donc je
voudrais bien distinguer par contre j'ai
demandé effectivement des informations
sur le parcours de cette personne qui
est entré en france en 2011 avec un visa
de long séjour qui va les titres de
séjour qui était valable jusqu'à
septembre 22 septembre 2012 il s'est
marié il a eu un titre de séjour valable
dans ce cadre là le 3 juin 2011
ce titre a été renouvelé ensuite tu 23
octobre 2002 jusqu'au 22 octobre 2013
il ya une rupture de vie commune il ya
eu un certain nombre d'éléments qui ont
été portées connaissance de
l'administration qui fait que
il ya eu un moment une occulter f parce
qu'il n'assumait plus ses
responsabilités vis-à-vis d'un enfant ce
que j'ai vu dans la presse me semble
juste mais il a ensuite changé de statut
la reprit sa responsabilité entre
guillemets locuteurs a été suspendue
dans ce cadre là elle va les 30 jours et
à ce moment là il ya une décision qui a
été prise
ensuite il ya eu un renouvellement de
titre à un moment il s'est retrouvé sans
titre puis je reprends la date exacte en
2000 suite
ainsi joe diop elle a été abrogée donc
l'occulté f le 24 août 2015 et une
nouvelle carte de séjour en qualité de
parents français étaient délivrés qui
était valable jusqu'en décembre 2017
c'est assez classique il sauf qu'il
s'est remarié il se trouve que il a
refait un enfant et qu'ensuite il a
demandé un nouveau titre de séjour qui
en 2018 lui a été accordé il lui a été
accordée avec une questionnement du
préfet du secrétaire général en charge
de ceux là qui a questionné la
commission départementale dont vous
savez qu'elle est composée d'anne élus
ou d'une élue en jeu ne l'est pas
l'indiquer madame la sénatrice mais vu
que vous le faites
voilà et il se trouve d'ailleurs que
c'est une sénatrice présente ici qui
présidait cette commission et j'ai lu le
compte rendu
je peux vous dire que les questions
étaient certainement peut-être plus
difficiles que celles auxquelles on a eu
droit laurent nunez et moi ce matin pour
comprendre je vous le confirme
pour comprendre le déroulé de ce qui
s'était passé et effectivement la
commission présidée par madame la
sénatrice a émis un avis favorable pour
qu'il ait un titre de séjour
c'était la séance du vendredi 14 juin
2019 et sur la base de cet avis
favorable il a eu un titre de séjour
d'un an
voilà je crois que la procédure allait
elle a concerné d'ailleurs je vous en
prie je ne vais pas vous citer mais que
vous l'avez fait et voilà la procédure
elle a été chaotique mais elle a été
régulière à tous les moments des
autorités qui ont eu à se prononcer en
2011 en 2014 en 2015 en 2018
et ça me permet de dire qu'on est sur un
champ assez large pour cela et puis
pardon
je voudrais vous répondre avant devaient
pardon c'est monsieur le président qui
préside avant que de notaire madame
delattre je le redis nous sommes sur
toutes vos questions dans le cadre de l'
enquête judiciaire
nous n'avons pas accès aux éléments dont
on parle la seule chose que y compris
les sms voilà la seule chose que je sais
c'est que au terme de l'examen des sms
et de la garde à vue de l'épouser elle
n'a pas été mise en examen ce qui ne
préjuge de rien il est important aussi
de dire cela et donc nous n'avons pas
accès à cela est la seule caisse sur
laquelle je peux vous répondre c'est
était-il fichier s non il n'était dans
aucun fichier
parce que à aucun moment il a été
identifié comme présenté un présentant
un risque de radicalisation et on en
revient pardon à la première question
que s'est il passé pour que un certain
nombre de signaux peut-être faible je
veux même pas les qualifier n'ait pas
fait l'objet de la procédure n'est pas
déclencher la procédure
c'est ce que nous devons comprendre et
c'est ce que nous devons faire en sorte
de changer
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur les
ministes ses explications mais c'est
précisément le problème auquel on est
confronté que de savoir qu'il y a dans
notre société et jusqu'au coeur de nos
administrations et jusqu'au coeur d'un
service de renseignement des individus
qui peut-être ont émis des signaux mais
dont les signaux qu'ils ont émis ont été
jugés plus faibles que des signaux
faibles donc de justifier
n'ayant pas de signalement est au fond
je crois que notre réflexion
depuis ce massacre de la préfecture de
police c'est de se dire mais comment
justement relever ce genre de défi
entièrement nouveau d'individus qui
alarme blanche dans des actions
individuelles même si l' enquête pourra
éventuellement établir des liens avec
des personnes associées des mouvances
islamistes radicales voire liée à des
acteurs du terrorisme et nous sommes
confrontés à quelque chose qui est
entièrement nouveau et nos schémas de
pensée ne peuvent pas s'y appliquer et
donc qu'est ce que nous pouvons imaginer
que moyen de détecter une partie au
moins de ces individus avec des méthodes
qui ne relève pas du signalement mais
plutôt d'une démarche par coup de sonde
une démarche aléatoire ou d'autres
méthodes qu'il appartient aux services
essayer de définir sous votre sous votre
autorité
avant de mettre fin à cette audition je
voudrais tout de même puisque un échange
a eu lieu sur ce point que madame sage
pregno puisse s'exprimer
je me rappelle très bien de les choses
que j'ai eu avec cet imam et si vous
lisez bien et vous l'avez lu le séisme
aura pas nous n'avions pas d'autre
solution que de lui délivrer un titre
puisqu'il était père d'un enfant
français donc il avait deux droits il
était même pas obligés de passer dans la
collision des titres de séjour il est
passé dans cette commission des titres
de séjour parce que je pense que
secrétaire général de préfecture
s'interrogeait sur la personnalité de
cet imam comme je me suis interrogé sur
la personnalité si mam parce que je vais
pas trahir les secrets cette commission
j'ai été extrêmement interpellé par ces
propos et d'ailleurs à la fin de la
commission j'avais demandé à ce qu'ils
soient signalés serre que c'est rare
dans ces commissions que nous le
fassions
et à la fin de l'audition j'avais dit
aux services des préfectures
il faut signaler au service qui s'occupe
pas de la science du territoire cet imam
qui a des propos tout à fait étonnant
vous avez un certain nombre de choses
mais de toute façon il avait un titre
séjour de droit pères d'enfants français
et le parcours chaotique de trouver une
femme puis une deuxième pour justifier
d'être perdant français pour rester
il est classique mais c'est vrai que je
me rappelle très très bien de cet
entretien qui bien évidemment est si
vous l'avez dit vous-même monsieur le
ministre mes questions et mise entretien
avec ce type de personnages vont très
loin
et les propos est que vous pouvez
regarder on est allé très très loin et
j'avais demandé ce qui se dessinait mais
qu'est ce qu'on pouvait faire d'autre
voilà c'est toute la limite de nos
systèmes monsieur le ministre c'est
toute la limite toutes les limites
vous souhaitez réagir monsieur le
ministre non je confirme fermeté des
questionnements et l'analyse juridique
qui vous a conduit à mettre un avis
favorable
effectivement pourquoi parce que la
commission n'ait pas saisi dans tous les
cas le secrétaire général souhaitait
bloqué ce dossier parce qu'effectivement
il ya une incohérence de parcours où on
voit bien que c'est quelqu'un qui sait
qui vient avec son avocat et qui sait
pertinement parfaitement utiliser les
règles de droit pour les contourner
on va dire je ne pensais pas au delà
plus globalement monsieur le président
merci de cette audition nous sommes
engagés sur quelques éléments
complémentaires et nous n'hésiterons pas
si vous avez des questions
supplémentaires à apporter tous les
éclaircissements que nous pouvons
apporter soit en utilisant la commission
soit la délégation pour certains sujets
dont nous aurions connaissance et qui ne
peuvent pas être rendus publics vous
dire qu'il ya à la fois une réponse
administrative mais il ya une réponse
politique
on l'a bien vu et je crois que cette
société de la vigilance que nous devons
construire
elle s'adapte au fait qu' on a en face
de nous des individus qui portent qu'une
parole de haine et qu'aujourd'hui on ne
peut pas se contenter de penser que
c'est une libre expression non c'est
condamnable ça implique de prendre un
risque et je voudrais pour conclure
évoqué juste cet appel à la
manifestation cet après midi il y avait
dans ce dossier un art il ya eu un
arbitrage le mien il y avait dans ce
dossier une dimension juridique une
dimension politique
la dimension juridique elle est
d'analyser la déclaration qui était fait
en aucun cas la déclaration de
l'individu portait sur une manifestation
pour soutenir l'auteur de la terre cpt
sa déclaration était très administrative
très habile et donc l'analyse juridique
pourrait conduire à dire il ya un risque
d'annulation
même si la notion d'ordre public doit
nous protéger de cela et ensuite il ya
une décision politique celle que j'ai
prise de considérer que les propos au
delà même de la déclaration de
l'organisation de cette manifestation
était indigne
insupportable et donc il était
nécessaire de prendre cette décision là
et au fond on voit bien que nous sommes
ici au sénat toujours entre la dimension
juridique qui est protectrice des
français et la dimension politique et
qu'il nous faut nous armer et nous armer
par le droit et nous armer aussi par
cette vigilance collective à laquelle
nous nous devons d'être acteur ce n'est
pas de la délation c'est de la
responsabilité
messieurs les ministres je vous remercie
au nom de tous les membres de la
commission nous attendons en effet des
compléments possible ce que vous avez
annoncé et en particulier ceux qui
seront destinés à la délégation
parlementaire au renseignement
la séance est levée